Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Kommen wir nun zu etwas völlig anderem.
Kommen wir aber zu, was vollkommen anderem, nämlich Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer zweihundertneunzehn liegt auf dem Abhörtisch bereit für euch in diesem Moment, in unserem Moment live aufgenommen.
Und ja, der Cybermarsch, der kam letztes Mal ganz gut an.
Der Cybermarsch kam gut an, wir sind ja noch in äh wir sammeln da noch so ein bisschen die die Antworten, die wir ja schon so bekommen haben. Es gibt da äh es werden,
Ähnlichkeiten zu anderen Stücken festgestellt, die historisch doch dann durchaus älter sind,
wir werden dem noch ein bisschen nachgehen. Ja, die werden.
Dass sie da kreativ sich bedient haben. Da kommt doch dann gleich das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium und sendet den Spezialberater.
Aber was ich, was ich sehr schön, na ja, andererseits kann's natürlich auch sagen, dass es äh gegenüber dem Bundesrechnungshof, dass das natürlich gut ist, wenn du Geld sparst, dadurch, dass du halt.
Einfach was nimmst, was schon mal da war.
Da war, ne? Ist ja eh so ein Militär, ist ja eh so, man nimmt sich was, was schon mal da war, ne? Land.
Wir müssen aufhören mit diesem Militärwitz.
Es wird schwierig, ne.
Aber was die, was tatsächlich die Leute, die Gemüter erhitzt hat, dann war die Frage, handelt es sich hier um einen vier vier Illtakt oder um einen sechs Achteltakt und es gab ähm.
Das sind die wichtigen Fragen des Lebens.
Es gab ähm,
also kommentiert den Seite. Eindeutig für vier, äh wer kommt, wie kommt man denn da auf sechs Achtel? Und ähm ich habe jetzt gerade noch eine Mail bekommen, die möchte ich mal ähm vorlesen, weil das ist jemand, der äh der hat Recht, ja.
Immer oder wie.
Äh nee, in diesem Fall zumindest. Eigentlich melde ich bei mich bei solchen Dingen nicht gleich zum Klugscheißen, aber da ich selber solche Musik beim Bund gemacht habe, kann ich gerade nicht anders. Also, der Cybermarsch ist ein Konzertmarsch,
Die sind in der Regel im Zwei-Viertel-Etakt geschrieben,
nie in Vierviertel, dass man nur bei Parade oder Trauermärschen. Und in aller Brewe, also zwo halbe. Dein Informant, also ich hatte ja äh ähm,
jemanden zitiert, der äh das Ding zunächst für einen vier vier Etakt gehalten hatte.
Kommt wohl aus der Popmusik. Das würde er weit von sich weisen. Äh da gibt es den vier Vierteltakt häufiger. Tatsächlich wird dieser Marsch aber im sechs Achtel geschrieben worden sein,
Warum? Das ist eine Feelingssache im sechs Achtel bildest du zwei Dreiergruppen von Achteln und lässt jeweils die zweite Achtel weg,
Oder jeweils die zwei Achtel weg? Setzt du diese Gruppen zu einem Takt zusammen, hast du Achtelpause, Achtel, Achtelpause, Achtel,
Dann kommt der nächste Takt. So entsteht ein Irrer Drive in der Rhythmusgruppe und das Stück wird dadurch fortgetragen und beschwingt. Man erzeugt in einer binären Bewegung dem Marsch oder,
marschieren, ein ternäres Feeling, denn es gibt auch Märsche, die für die Bewegung geschrieben worden sind und im sechsachtel notiert sind. Die Amis machen das viel,
So Samärsche oder Susa-Märsche sind oft im sechsachtel wie Liverty Bell oder Washington Post ähm oder im Deutschen der Alexandermarsch,
Die Sachen hast du bestimmt schon mal gehört, nur nicht bewusst darauf geachtet, ja, kann gut sein.
Kauben.
Ähm eure Bundeswehrkritik in der letzten Sendung fand ich sehr interessant. Ich würde, wenn ich ein Hacker wäre, zum Bund gehen und den Wandel im System versuchen, um genau wie bei euch erwähnt, ein Wandel,
Ernährung zu erreichen. Ich war ja selber Zeitsoldat, allerdings habe ich die einzig wahre und richtige passive Wehrdienstverweigerung gemacht. Da ich bei der Militärmusik war, was jetzt auch erklärt, warum dieser Mensch so viel Ahnung hat,
innerhalb der Truppe waren wir der Abschaum und haben uns da,
und wir haben das auch immer zu spüren bekommen. Ich glaube sogar die zivilen Mitarbeiter haben mehr Respekt gezollt bekommen als wir. Nichtsdestotrotz war ich gerne dabei
und dachte euch, würde etwas Sinnvolles machen. Ich würde vermuten, dass die Cybertruppe innerhalb der kämpfenden Truppe bald genauso verschrien ist, wie die LWs, die Militärmusik innerhalb der Bundeswehr ist. Musiker,
Können genauso wenig mit Hierarchien anfangen wie Hacker. Und spätestens wenn in Mannheim in Klammern Verpflegungssaal der Mannschaftsdienst gerade Club Mate zu den Panzerkeksen gereicht wird, könnte es zu ernsthaften Tumulten mit Hang, zu Blut
Tat kommen. Das wird fein,
Ja, die Mail haben wir aber auch mal im in Gänze vorgelesen.
Fantastisch. Also das, also das, das, dass die Musiker da jetzt äh so ein, so ein so ein schwaches soziales Standing haben, das überrascht mich jetzt ehrlich.
Hätte ich auch gedacht, das sind da die einzigen, die noch irgendwie ein bisschen positive PR machen.
Jahren, die vor allem auch mal so ein bisschen im Ruf stehen, da so das Urkonservative äh durch die Seele zu tragen, aber das äh wird dann wahrscheinlich dann doch ein bisschen anders bewertet.
Also danke Moritz für dieses Feedback. Ich werde jetzt einfach mal zur allgemeinen Policy machen, dass sich bei sowas äh bei E-Mails dann den Vornamen nenne oder das Pseudonym, was oben steht, aber kein Nachname. Weil da steht jetzt nichts dabei, euch.
Es sei denn, es sei denn, es steht explizit dabei das nicht. Wir haben also ein Opt-Outverfahren hier, also also jetzt an diesem.
No Privacy bei Deford.
Nur Haftprivacy bei die Folge.
Ähm.
Genau, so viel, so viel dazu, ich vielleicht noch ganz kurz, ich habe mich mit mehreren Bundeswehrsoldaten in letzter Zeit über diese Bundeswehrgeschichte unterhalten
gerade auch gestern ein sehr beeindruckendes Gespräch mit jemandem geführt, der ähm,
Insgesamt also äh über fünfhundert Tage im Auslandseinsatz war ähm in Irak und Afghanistan unterwegs und was ähm.
Was die Leute da so mitmachen müssen ist echt eine ernsthafte Geschichte, insofern.
Möchte ich da jetzt nicht irgendwie jemanden zu nahe treten, wenn wir uns über die gesamte Idee der Bundeswehr äh lustig machen. Ähm.
Die gesamte Idee der Cyberwehr.
Dass die Idee der Cyber wäre vielleicht, also ich möchte auf jeden Fall glaube ich, man muss da irgendwie die Trennung finden zwischen sich über diese Institution lustig machen und über
über die Menschen, die da teilweise echt einen Scheiß mitmachen müssen, der äh weit über alles hinausgeht, was man sich irgendwie vorstellen kann als normalsterblicher, äh zu dessen Schutz diese Leute unterwegs sind. Insofern.
Möchte ich da jetzt nicht irgendwie.
Oder sei es jetzt durch konkrete Einsätze mit Gefährdung des äh eigenen Lebens.
Kameraden die dann da auch mal.
Oder auch nur die totale Langweile von von Rekruten, die irgendwo ähm Kosovo eingesperrt irgendwie da Präsenz absetzen, aber im Prinzip nicht viel zu tun haben und Däumchen drehen und Podcast hören.
Und Scart Spiel.
Da wirklich hier wirklich zu allem.
Eine Meinung auch.
Nicht nur also wir haben vielleicht äh zwei alte Meinungen, aber noch besser ist, es zeigt sich eigentlich, es wir können noch so absurde Themen anschneiden, es findet sich in der Hörerschaft,
Experte, der es deutlich besser weiß und da einfach Einblicke hat. Äh insofern.
Freut, also ich freue mich immer, wenn bei, wenn man solche Nachrichten kriegt, macht das gerne.
Insbesondere so aus der Ferne. Es ist ja auch äh keine Neuigkeit, das Podcast, insbesondere bei äh Expats oder halt auch solchen Expats ist ja an der Stelle nicht der richtige Name, aber halt so Leute, die im Ausland weilen müssen und so ein bisschen äh äh,
Armut an Sozialbezug äh äh zu ihrer gewohnten Kultur haben und ich glaube nichts vermittelt, kulturelle Nähe zu zur Heimat, so sehr wie ein Podcast.
Meinst du, wir sind hier so ein Heimatbook?
Das also es gilt für alle Podcasts, nicht.
Also ich hab tatsächlich schon in den in den entlegensten Orten der Erde Logbuchnetzpolitik hörer getroffen. Ähm ja.
Ja ähm jüngst auch wieder, ne? Genau, ich bin übrigens die Tage in Ochsford, einen Tag, falls jemand am dritten Mai äh Zeit hat.
Sowas mache ich ja in der Regel nicht. Das Ankündigen. Aber okay.
Das muss man ja ankündigen, wenn man dann nur einen Tag da ist.
Wenn man nur einen Tag da ist.
Genau, mache ich noch einen kleinen Link äh da drauf fällt mir jetzt gerade so nebenbei noch ein.
So, dann haben wir ein.
Ein äh relativ wichtigen Kommentar von ähm Michael Kreill, dessen ähm dessen Projekt, wie er in der letzten Woche behandelt haben, der einen wichtigen Punkt bringt und ähm ich der mir nicht so klar war, er sagt.
So jetzt sagst du erstmal, welches Projekt wir behandelt haben und dass äh Michael Kreil natürlich auch schon mal zu Gast war, haben wir auch schon erwähnt, äh erwähnen wir nochmal.
Michael Kreil, ähm Datenjournalist inzwischen bei dem Tagesspiegelteam, das ähm,
letzte Woche diese drei Analysen zur zu AfD Twitter-Accounts,
Zusammen mit Netzpolitik Ork veröffentlicht hat, war so eine äh Zusammenarbeit hauptsächlich von Markus Reuter und Michael Kreil und eben dem
großartigen äh Team, das Michael um sich rum hat. Lisa Charlotte Rost und wer da so alles äh beißt. Dieser Charlotte hatte ich glaube ich auch erwähnt, dass er einen Vortrag beim Kongress gehalten hat, der Day Toupoint, Walks in Tool Bar. Ähm
der natürlich hier nochmal empfohlen sei,
Genau, die Wiesen also darauf hin, dass ich ja kurz gescherzt habe, dass man den äh den Zugang zu seinem Twitter-Account spenden kann, damit sie eben diese API Limits von Twitter irgendwie über äh äh umgehen können oder.
Großzügig auslegen können.
Und ähm dabei habe ich aber, habe ich den Vergleich zu diesem Twitter-Counter gezogen, der ähm bei Boris Becker eben dazu geführt hat, dass er äh auf einmal ne sich gegen die,
Also das, dass sich türkische Hacker seiner äh seines Accounts bemächtigt haben, Lokbuch, Netzpolitik berichtete. Was ich nicht erwähnt habe, ist, dass ähm dieses Team.
Dass du also ein Twitter token
In unterschiedlichen Zugriffsebenen und Tiefen haben kannst. Also wenn du so ein Aufenthalt token hast und den quasi beantragt, also den gerade austeilst, dann steht dort du wirst jetzt diese Applikation erlauben, Folgendes zu tun,
sowas wie deine Timeline lesen.
Nachricht, Tweets posten, direkt Messages lesen und schreiben oder so. Da gibt es also ein ein Rechtekonzept, das sich in diesem Token abbildet.
Und ähm es kann also sehr gut sein, dass die eine oder viele solcher viral auf Viralität auf.
Abzielender, Applikationen wollen natürlich auch twittern, weil sie für sich selber werben wollen und ähm diese.
Also nicht unbedingt immer automatisch, aber zumindest so, dass der User dann sagt, und jetzt will ich's auch noch twittern und dann macht dann die App das eben so, ja genau.
Aber Data Science in Stories haben also ein,
ähm wollen Existokens haben, die lesen können und nutzen die nur zu diesem Zweck. Und hier steht dann nämlich Disaplication Werbeable Tweets From Your Timeline.
NC ho you follow.
It we not be able two, follow new people, Update your profil, Post, Weets for you, excess your direct Messages, see you E-Mail, Adresse, all see you twitter Password. Also sie haben das minimal
Konzept, was sie äh brauchen für das, was sie hier tun,
Michael hat freundlicherweise nochmal darauf hingewiesen, dass sie nur Readoly Talkens haben und keine Tweets,
absenden und beißt nochmal kurz darauf hin, dass es eben unter HTTPS Talken Punkt DSST Punkt IO Data Science,
Punkt IO. Ähm die Möglichkeit gibt diesen Token zu spenden und das dauert äh nicht lange und tut nicht weh.
Und sie haben inzwischen hundertzweiundsechzig und die können noch sehr viel mehr machen. Hier kann man schönen Datenjournalismus
unterstützen von coolen Leuten mit wenig Aufwand und kostet kein Geld. Also nochmal der Aufruf, macht das ruhig mal, ähm, das Risiko ist an dieser Stelle gering und die Leute sind,
vertrauenswürdig.
Also ist hier gar kein Risiko, also nur wenn sie es total übertreiben mit der Accountnutzung und dann irgendwie der Countdown irgendwie runtergef.
Genau ist, ich ich weiß tatsächlich nicht, ob dieses AP-Limit pro Pro App pro Token oder pro Account ist. Ähm na, also es könnte ja sehr gut sein, dass du so und so viele Sequenz pro Minute machen darfst.
Da das Turken gilt für den Account und die App siehst du dann quasi nicht mehr, weil das nicht mehr äh Countreifen machen kannst. Also es ist halt Protoken. Aber ich schätze mal, sie könnten ich wüsste nicht.
Weil dann könnten sie auch einfach mehrere Apps machen.
Na ja, du brauchst halt trotzdem Erlaubnisse sozusagen. Ja, sie könnten jetzt hier sagen, irgendwie mit deinem Account kannst du hier zehn Mal äh klicken und so weiter, ja.
Weiß ich nicht, ob das geht. Dann würden sie aber wahrscheinlich von Twitter relativ schnell auf den Sack.
Ja das kann alles sein. Egal, ich hab das jetzt mal auf jeden Fall gemacht, hier sind wir bei hundertzweiundsechzig, mal gucken, wo wir nach Veröffentlichung dieser Sendung plus acht Stunden liegen.
Enttäuscht uns nicht. Wir haben Datenjournalisten an dieser Zahl dran.
Wir wollen eine schöne Kurve sehen.
Wollen eine schöne Kurve.
Sonst kommen wir uns wieder unwichtig vor. Unser Körner mehr zu. Und wenn, dann machen sie nichts, wenn wir was sagen.
So.
Wenn es schon nicht protestiert und die Regierung stürzt, dann macht das nichts. Twittertons auch. Genau.
Genau. Wo warst du.
Als Michael Kreil einen Toten brauch.
So, dann haben wir noch einen kurzen äh eine Ergänzung von einem gewissen Idif, äh der äh ergänzt ähm was äh die Herauslösung des BMI aus des BF,
DI aus dem BMI angeht. Also wir haben ja letzte Woche darüber gesprochen, das ja äh die Datenschutz äh
die die Beauftragte für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit irgendwann aus dem Innenministerium herausgelöst wurde und Ilf äh stell äh ergänzt die,
BFDI wurde zwar aus dem BMI rausgelöst,
Aber nur, weil EU-Recht das vorschreibt und der EuGH Deutschland verurteilt hat.
Die Bundesregierung hat sich bis zuletzt dagegen gesträubt, eine Lösloslösung des BSI förderfordern Grüne und Linke aber eben nicht Union,
SPD entsprechend, ne?
Wie ich vermeide, eher weit in weiter Ferne, dass das tatsächlich mal passiert. Ähm und dann auch ein ganz kurzer Satz. Im Übrigen bin ich der Meinung, dass die Bundeswehr abgeschafft gehört statt ausgebaut.
Danke auch für für diese Ergänzung.
Und dann mit der, einer der wichtigsten eine der wichtigsten Ergänzungen von Co zum äh
zum zu der Software, die wir besprochen haben mit der Wahlen ausgezählt werden. Ähm, da hatten wir ja letzte Woche die Antwort auf die kleine Anfrage verlesen. Übrigens den den klügsten
ist aufgefallen, dass diese kleine Anfrage nirgendwo online stand und dann kam Nachfrage, wo der Linis die denn wohl her hatte. Ja.
Ja, der hat Quellen.
Quellen, ja, nicht jede E-Mail, die bei uns eingeht, wird vorgelesen und äh braune Umschläge kommen auch immer mal wieder vorbei und sind auch immer wieder gerne gesehen.
Ähm der Einsatz der Software in der Wahl in den Niederländern ist und war sehr eingeschränkt
Zitat übersetzt aus dem Brief des Ministers. Also das nimmt darauf Bezug, dass er in der kleinen Anfrage geantwortet wurde in,
das Verbot wäre nicht aufrecht erhalten worden und diese Software sei in den Niederlanden eingesetzt worden. Da
timt faktisch erstmal, aber äh man muss eben dazu sagen, dass es sehr strenge Einschränkungen gab, wie diese Software genutzt wurde und darüber ist hier die äh das äh die der Wahlleiter oder wer auch immer, da die kleine Anfrage beantwortet hat,
ähm hinweggegangen. Ähm,
Und Zitat aus dem Minister, die USV-Funktionalität ist brauchbar als Rechenhilfsmittel. Wie ein Spray, ein Rechenhilfsmittel ist, wenn dafür gesorgt wird, dass das,
dass der Papierprozess leitend ist. Also, ne, die was dir
Der autoratiative Prozess ist, dass das Papier gezählt wird und nicht, äh dass dass die Software irgendwas macht. Die Wahl hat vier Stufen. Die Wahl ist Wahllokal, etwa eintausende
davon gibt es zehntausend davon gibt's im ganzen Land, dann geht's zum Hauptwahllokal, das befindet sich auf Gemeinde oder Stadtebene, dann zum Wahlkreis, wie etwa wie die Provinz und dann zum nationalen Wahlrat.
Die Stimmen werden manuell gezählt im Wahllokal, das Papier.
Wird für alle Wahllokale im Hauptwahllokal mit der fraglichen Software reduziert zu einem einzigen Resultat und auf Papier zum Wahlkreis gebracht, wo es wieder genauso reduziert wird. Ja, also dass du einen mehrstufigen.
Aggregationsprozess. Aber die Resultate pro Partei werden in allen Stufen noch einmal manuell ohne die Software berechnet und die Zählung ist,
leitend. Vorbedingungen, das Hilfsmittel darf nur auf Computern benutzt werden, die nicht mit dem Internet verbunden sind. Für alle Stufen gilt das Vier-Augen-Prinzip. Jede Stufe wird mit der Hand eingeführt, also keine elektronischen Datenträger,
Noch ein Zitat, der Prozess ist die Summe der Stimmen äh,
A der Prozess zu der Summe der Stimmen muss transparent und kontrollierbar sein, ne.
Nun verlinkt ist eben der Brief des Ministers über die Benutzung des Software auf niederländisch und die Untersuchung von Fox IT äh dieser äh Software auch auf niederländisch und ähm.
Ja, vielen Dank, dass ähm.
Bin ganz vorsichtig, aber ich glaube, der die Person, die diesen Kommentar verfasst hat, ist auch äh niederländische Muttersprachlerin und ähm hat hier mal wieder,
offenbar sehr viel Ahnung, vielleicht könnte das ja sogar jemand sein
der sich da genau mit auseinandergesetzt hat. Ähm auf jeden Fall beides nochmal hier verlinkt und ähm auch eine wichtige Ergänzung, dass äh die eigentlich natürlich auch nochmal zu dieser kleinen Anfrage gegeben werden müsste.
Ja, schöner Trend, dass jetzt unsere Themen auch wirklich über mehrere Sendungen hinweg weiter angereichert werden. Das äh also zuletzt auch nicht so in dem Maß. Aber vielleicht liegt's auch nur an uns, dass wir uns, das Feedback genauer anschauen und mehr in die Sendung tragen. Das ist wahrscheinlich.
Ich glaube.
Schlichte, kein schlechter Move.
Das machen wir jetzt öfter. So.
So ja und dann.
Was wir ja eigentlich mal machen könnten, wäre ähm die Polizei schützen.
Ja, die, die steht nämlich äh.
Die steht unter äh Überwachung, wie es äh den Anschein hat. So.
Lautet zumindest das Fazit des Spiegels, der wohl vertrauliche Unterlagen äh und das das genau aufgeschlüsselt wird, was für vertrauliche Unterlagen, das äh sind ausgewertet hat
und zu dem Schluss kommt, dass der BND offenbar mehrere Jahre lang Interpol ausspieleniert hat,
Ähm nicht nur die Zentrale, die in Lyon, in Frankreich sitzt, sondern auch Verbindungsbüros unter anderem Österreich, Dänemark, Belgien, Griechenland, Spanien,
Italien, USA wird da vor allem genannt, aber das zieht sich wohl über den kompletten Erdball und auch nicht nur Interpol war hier das Ziel der Operation, sondern wohl auch Europol,
Das ist dann quasi der EU-Angegliedert und auch sonstige nationale Polizeidienststellen. Sprich, hier,
sieht es so aus, als ob der Nachrichtendienst sich vor allem Interpol angeschaut hat, wo man vielleicht nochmal kurz erwähnen.
Was Interpool eigentlich ist.
Offiziell ist es ein Verein tatsächlich, Verein zur Stärkung der Zusammenarbeit, nationaler Polizeibehörden, da sind dann Staatenmitglied.
In Frankreich, hundertneunzig Mitgliedsstaaten sind dabei, also es ist schon eine recht globale äh Geschichte, kann euch jetzt nicht im Einzelnen aufzählen, wer da äh vor allem nicht dabei ist. Das weiß ich nicht
und gibt da wohl auch irgendeine Kommission, die sich ein paar Mal im Jahr trifft und äh die Arbeit natürlich überwacht, weil ne gehört sich ja so, wissen wir ja auch, wie gut das funktioniert.
Also zumindest bei den Nachrichtendiensten in Deutschland, ne
Das ist natürlich jetzt auf mehreren Ebenen sehr interessant, ne? Also zunächst einmal, dass natürlich der Nachrichtendienst überhaupt die Polizei
selbst auch nochmal als Informationsquelle äh absaugt. Gut,
Insider mögen hier vielleicht nicht überrascht sein, aber ist halt immer schön überraschend, wenn man das dann auch mal so äh vor die Nase gehalten bekommt. Zumal ja nun ausgerechnet in Deutschland die Tätigkeit der Nachrichtendienste und die Tätigkeit der Polizei, zumindest auf dem Papier,
eigentlich ja strikt getrennt sein soll. Das betrifft natürlich, höre ich jetzt schon die erste Ausrede wieder äh vor allem äh.
Deutschen Nachrichtendienste und die deutsche Polizei, ja? Da ist ja ein ein Erbe
und eine Lehre auch aus der Zeit des Nationalsozialismus, wo man halt diese Trennung eben nicht hatte und damit natürlich die Bevölkerung viel mehr in die Mangel äh nehmen konnte und ja auch,
extrem in die Mangel genommen hat und das wollte man dann eben nicht mehr haben. Drum wurde es ins Grundgesetz geschrieben, dass das eben,
nichts miteinander zu tun haben darf.
Inwiefern wir das in den letzten fünfzig, sechzig Jahren dann auch mal so durchgehalten haben, steht natürlich auf dem anderen Blatt Papier.
Überwachungsmaßnahmen waren offenbar E-Mail, Telefon und Fax,
auch nicht tot zu kriegen, ja? Das äh waren hier wohl diese Lektoren, sprich mit anderen Worten, aus welcher Überwachungsquelle auch immer wurden eben solche Datenströme abgegriffen und überwacht,
Zu welchen Schlüssen hier irgendjemand gekommen sein mag, unklar. Ähm,
auf jeden Fall ein ähm erstaunliches Treiben. Weitere Details sind jetzt so noch nicht bekannt, wir beziehen uns hier auf eine Vorabmeldung des Spiegel und das Ganze wird
im nächsten gedruckten Heft dann wohl etwas ausführlicher beleuchtet. Mal gucken wie äh dick die dann da auftragen. Ähm,
unbestätigt ist, dass äh die Regierung vorhat, diesem Treiben durch eine Erhöhung des BND-Budgets äh Einheit zu gebie.
Es ist ein reines Gerücht.
Oh man, ey.
Ja. Also sehr viel mehr kann man dazu jetzt äh zumindest jetzt mit unserer Nachrichtenlage äh nicht sagen, was in dir noch was so einfällt.
Oder fällt dir da schon nichts mehr so ein.
Mir fällt da nichts mehr zu ein, ne? Also da wird.
Schon gut, dass ihr also Interpol sollte tatsächlich auch jemand kontrollieren, aber ob das jetzt ausredet, der BTE, äh der, der, der, ähm, BND sein sollte, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht.
Ja, das ist äh fraglich, ne. Das ist fraglich. Ja. Und was war noch.
Ja, du äh es gab eine große große Tumult ähm über diese U-Bahn-Geschichte.
Ach ja genau.
Also ich nehme das jetzt einfach mal zur Kenntnis, wie wir kurz lachend darüber hinweg gehen, wie der BND Interpol aushört. Und als nächstes mit irgendeiner iPhone-App auseinandersetzen. Ich nehme das mal, äh ich nehme das mal als äh.
Genau.
Zur Kenntnis. Die also das musst du mir jetzt mal genau erklären. Ähm.
Die Geschichte ist Uwe hat Leute getrackt, auch wenn sie die App deinstalliert hatten.
Das ist so, dass wir so ein bisschen gekreist hat so als Kurzmeldungen auf Twitter.
Wo man denkt, boah, krass. Also bei Uber denkst du ja auch vor allem erstmal so ein Location-Base-Tracking, ne.
Und vor allem auf dem iPhone.
Auf dem iPhone, das geht ja wohl.
Geht ja wohl gar nicht. Geht ja wohl gar nicht. Genau und was.
Das geht ja wohl gar nicht. Aber warum sollte das nicht funktionieren? Erstens, weil sie ja die App die installiert hast und ähm dann sollte ja auch alles weg sein. Ne, also es sollte ja alles, es das sollte ja wirklich nicht gehen.
Ja. Also räumen wir mal ein bisschen auf, was was eigentlich wirklich passiert ist. Das Ganze geht jetzt äh zunächst einmal zurück auf eine Meldung der New York Times
die ähm den Artikel, den sie darüber veröffentlicht haben, dann auch noch ein, zwei Mal nachbearbeitet hat und gerade dieser Trekking äh Vorwurf ist dann so
im Nachgang dann auch wieder zurückgefahren worden. Die Darstellung war ähm,
Sagen wir mal etwas Missliedingen, wie man so schön sagt heutzutage. Es gab wohl ein Treffen von Apple Chef Tim Cook und dem äh berüchtigten CO von äh Uber diesen,
Karla Nick, der schon durch äh diverse andere unangenehme Vorfälle gerade in der letzten Zeit
sehr unangenehm aufgefallen ist, aber es ist ja auch nicht das allererste Mal, dass sie unangenehm auffallen, hier kommt jetzt allerdings
einiges zusammen. So und ähm in diesem Gespräch zwischen Tim Cook und Kalernick hat wohl äh Tim Kook, also Apple quasi Uhr damit gedroht, sie aus ihrem App Store rauszuschmeißen
eben weil sie ein illegales Tracking äh betrieben hätten mit ihrer App ähm da gibt's jetzt.
Wenig wirklich verlässliche technische Details, also zumindest hat Apple keine bekannt gegeben, Apple hat auch dieses Treffen nicht bekannt gegeben, es ist auch nicht klar
die New York Times an diese Information rangekommen ist, aber äh widersprochen wurde dem jetzt wohl auch nicht.
Der Vorwurf lautet also ähm ein Tracking von Usern nachdem sie eine einmal installierte und eingerichtete UBA-App wieder gelöscht haben,
Das scheint jetzt so.
Also erstmal da kann man sofort technische Zweifel dran haben, ja? Weil 'ne App, die nicht mehr auf dem Telefon ist, kann in dem Sinne eigentlich nichts mehr tun. Wenn wenn das tatsächlich so wäre
dann hätte diese App ja in irgendeiner Form etwas zurücklassen müssen und das kann man dann eigentlich nur noch als ähm Malware bezeichnen
und das kann man zum,
Unter dem derzeitigen Kenntnisstand über äh die Geschichte insgesamt wohl ausschließen. Also hier kam keine Malwehr im eigentlichen Sinne zum,
zum Einsatz, das würde ja bedeuten, dass das iPhone da quasi aufgebrochen worden wäre von der Ober-App und so weiter und ich glaube, wenn das passiert wäre, dann hätte Tim Cook sich noch nicht mal mit uns hier unterhalten, sondern hätte dem einfach direkt den Squat äh geschickt und den irgendwie abgeräumt.
Worauf das Ganze aber jetzt ein Licht
wirft ist was Uber so an sich macht, weil das hier ein Tracking stattgefunden hat, das ist ja das kann man als bestätigt wohl ansehen. Und das Ganze geht wohl darauf zurück
oder unter anderem drauf zurück, dass es
das natürlich auch Uber mit diversen Betrugsszenarien zu tun hat. Zum Beispiel wurde in China, anderen Ländern wohl auch zwanzig vierzehn gab so ein weit verbreitetes Betrugsszenario in dem U-Bahnfahrer
sich einfach so zusätzliche iPhones noch geholt haben, sich da irgendwelche neuen Apple-IDs eingerichtet haben, die UBAP installiert haben und sich dann quasi selbst bestellt haben
Weil es nämlich für viele angenommene Fahrten dann äh Boni gab und sie sozusagen über diesen Weg versucht haben, über äh quasi selber dann nochmal zu bescheißen. Und um das zu verhindern
hat Uber wohl offenbar Wege gesucht, wie sie ähm während die Ab noch da ist, ein Fingerprint anlegen,
Also quasi so eine so ein Datenstring äh generieren auf Basis vorgefundener Informationen auf diesem Telefon. Das selbst wenn das Telefon danach platt gemacht wird, neu installiert wird,
Die Uwe ab neun installiert wird ein ganz neuer Account, da ankommt, dass man trotzdem erkennen kann.
Das ist doch hier dieses Telefon, das war doch vorhin schon da und das hat jetzt irgendwie alle paar Stunden hat das irgendwie einen neuen Account äh euch nehmen wir jetzt mal raus.
Das ist, sagen wir mal so, ein.
Der Versuch war ein ein spezifisches Telefon.
Zu erkennen, genau.
Was nämlich hat ja eine Vorgeschichte, das ging ja eine Zeit lang und dann wurde das aber von Apple eigentlich unterbunden, ne?
Naja und gut, was da ging, also es gab im frühen Versionen und da reden wir jetzt so um diese Zeit bis ähm sechs, sieben vielleicht,
da gab's also zwanzig zwölf zum Beispiel ähm wurde äh erstmalig der Zugriff auf diese User Device ID,
gesperrt. Da war natürlich der Hauptanlass natürlich diese ganzen Werbetrecker, die das alles munter ausgelesen haben. Muss sagen, am Anfang war die Arp hier halt doch noch relativ offen und man hatte ja auch diese ganzen Betrugsszenarien so noch nicht in Massen erlebt und dann,
Trat das natürlich gehäuft auf und seitdem hat Apple die Identifizierungsmöglichkeiten eines Telefons stark zurückgefahren. Dann wurden natürlich auf andere Sachen wurde zugegriffen. Die Mac Adresse von dem WLAN-Device ist natürlich da auch sehr beliebt
ähm sowas rauszubekommen,
auch da wurde ein Riegel vorgeschoben, also zahlreiche Wege, solche Eindeutigkeiten zu bekommen, auch die Seriennummer.
Wurden Zugumzug geschlossen. Man kann davon ausgehen, dass irgendwo so zwischen iOS acht oder spätestens mit äh iOS zehn
eigentlich diese ganzen offensichtlichen Dinge äh wechseln. Jetzt weiß man nicht, welche andere Methoden sie noch gefunden haben,
selbst wenn es nicht eindeutig ist, könnten sie ja zumindest Anhaltspunkte haben et cetera äh ja Geo-Location, bla bla bla, da kann man ja alles Mögliche kombinieren, kennen wir ja auch,
heutzutage ist die AI ja in der Lage irgendwie ein rosa Elefanten
auf der Straßenbahnstraße, der von links nach rechts läuft, äh mal eben schnell zu erkennen, da sollte es ja auch noch möglich sein, irgendwie so ein Telefon. Ähm irgendwie wiederzuerkennen. Trotz alledem
Diese Lücken wurden geschlossen und selbst die Sachen, die ähm zwar möglich waren, waren zu dem Zeitpunkt schon verboten. Kann also gut sein, dass allein schon
dieses Bi Helvia U-Bahn ordentlich eins über die Mütze bekommen hat und einfach da das Messer auf die Brust gesetzt bekommen hat von Apple gesagt hat, wenn ihr diesen Scheiß jetzt nicht sein lasst, dann habt ihr einfach mal gleich kein Markt mehr, so und das kann sich natürlich Uber wiederum auch nicht leisten.
Um das gleich nochmal kurz. Also diese Apps sind ja auf einem iPhone relativ stark äh
abgeschottet vom Rest des Systemes und das Ziel ist eben eigentlich das so zu schaffen, dass die App nichts weiteres über das Gerät weiß,
oder über die auf dem Gerät installierten.
Applikationen oder irgendetwas über das Gerät weiß, was ihr, was über das hinausgeht, was was der Nutzer selber in dieses Ding eingibt
somit also nach der Löschung
die App nicht mehr und nicht weniger über den Nutzer weiß, als er ihr anvertraut hat und ähm deswegen funktioniert es eben auch, die App einfach danach nochmal neu zu installieren und Uber hatte eben keine sollte eigentlich keine Möglichkeit haben zu erkennen, dass das jetzt das gleiche iPhone ist oder eben ein anderes.
Und das haben sie aber dann doch hingekriegt, wie haben sie das denn gemacht.
Ähm na ja also unter anderem wurde eine äh App Version von der Uber-App von zwanzig vierzehn, von irgendjemandem nochmal sitziert. Äh man kann ja sich diese Apps da nehmen und dann mit die Baggerwerkzeugen et cetera, das kennst du ja alles besser als ich.
Schauen, was für Systemzugriffe werden jetzt gemacht und es gibt ja immer diese privaten APIs, ne? Das sind sozusagen
Ein Sprungpunkte ins Betriebssystem, die zwar da sind, aber halt offiziell nicht benutzt werden dürfen. Teilweise werden die halt in diesem Upstore,
Prozess schon automatisiert abgefangen und dann kriegt man das gleich um die Ohren geschmissen, aber äh da kann auch immer mal was äh entgehen und es wurden auch zahlreiche Methoden gefunden, das zu verschleiern. Das hat sich alles verbessert, es kann sehr gut sein, dass das heutzutage nicht möglich war, aber
in dieser zwanzig vierzehn App von vor drei Jahren wurde halt ähm festgestellt, dass hier zum Beispiel über irgendwelche privaten AEO,
äh dann doch die Seriennummer extrahiert wurde. Auch dieser technische Vorgang ging nicht mehr, aber mit einer Seriennummer hast du natürlich äh
ne? Ich meine, dass die Eigenschaft einer Seriennummer. Damit weißt du nun mal ganz genau, was äh ist so.
Also diese privaten APIs sind bestimmte Betriebssystem oder bestimmte iOS Funktionen, die Apple gerne, also die sie selber in ihren eigenen Apps nutzen.
Ja, du willst ja in deine Settings dir auch mal deine Seelennummer anzeigen lassen können, also muss ja auch irgendwie ermittelbar sein, ne.
Irgendwie einen Call, dass du sie kriegst und den darf aber eigentlich keiner nutzen. Ähm geht aber auch andere Dinge, ne? Also ich glaube irgendwie was was gibt's denn noch? Also,
es gibt eine ganze Reihe, Dinge, die du mit so einem iPhone machen kannst,
die die häufig dann Apple Apps vorbehalten sind und häufig hast du dann auch so, dass es dann irgendwie neue Funktionen sind, wo sie wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen darauf warten, bis sie mal stabil sind oder so,
Und dann kommt eine neue IOS-Version und jetzt dürfen die Entwickler auch die API, was weiß ich nutzen, um das Display heller und dunkler zu machen, weil Apple, die so gebaut hat, dass man da jetzt nichts mehr kaputt machen kann und ähm.
Und deswegen äh erlauben sie's dann. Und die, die eben schädlich sind, verbieten sie. Jetzt waren die aber doch eins, wenn du nämlich sowas äh wenn du deine App reinwirfst, dann läuft jedoch im Zweifelsfall durch irgendeine Form von,
Ähm von, ich würde das jetzt eine dynamische Analyse nennen, wo einfach mal alle Tasten äh alle aktiven Elemente in der App gedrückt werden
man guckt, ob da ob die App dann irgendwelche Calls macht, in den Quellcodes können die ja nicht schauen, du, du, du schickst ja ein Komplit
In den in den App Store. Also wird im, im Rahmen des Prüfprozesses irgendwie durchgeführt,
Ähm wird alles mal durchgeführt. Was, was früher, ich weiß nicht, das sind viele Jahre her, da hatte das iPhone kein Tavering. Oder nur wenn der, wenn der.
Anbieter das erlaubt hat. Also es war eine Sache des Carria Profils, ob dein iPhone tettern durfte oder nicht. Deutschlands iPhones dürfen das natürlich nicht klar, weil wir ja äh wäre ja eine sinnvolle Funktion gewesen.
Also ist auch immer noch so, nur dass es halt in der Regel erlaubt ist jetzt.
Ach so, okay. Und ähm da gab's dann so Taschenlampen-Apps. Das weiß ich, das war eine ganz geile, ganze Taschenlampenapp, wo du die Farbe ändern konntest, wie,
Also wie das Display jetzt ist, ne? Das war noch ein, das war glaube ich noch das Telefon, hatte noch gar keine LED drin, das war irgendwie auf iPhone eins oder so, das hat zwei
Zeiten. Das hatte noch gar kein Licht, aber der Gotteszeit, es gab halt die Flashlight-App war, das ganze Display ist weiß oder ganz violett und dann konnte es halt und dann gab's natürlich, die haben diese App da durch den App Store gepresst und dann haben sie irgendwie nachher halt gesagt, als die ausreichend runtergeladen wurde, haben sie halt gesagt, ja übrigens
Rot-Grün-Rot, Violett, Blau, Gelb, Grün, Grün, Violet, dann habt ihr Tesla und dann halt haben wir diese private API äh Appy dann genutzt,
im App Store Prüfprozess hat er halt kam die halt zwei hin und her geschoben, aber eben nicht bemerkt, dass diese Funktionalität da drin war. Die Epp war sofort raus, aber so kann man eben.
Sachen verstecken in oder konnte man und das muss Uwe doch jetzt auch gemacht haben, nur dass die das ja immer machen wollten.
Und deswegen diese Funktionalität irgendwie vor also diesen Aufruf irgendwie so machen mussten, dass er unter echten Bedingungen sofort funktioniert oder aber unter den Laborprüfbedingungen nicht stattfinden wird.
Genau, das ist so die Volkswagenmethode, ja? Also man erkennt, dass man auf dem Labor Prüfstand ist. Äh da haben sie sich zum Beispiel das Geofensings bedient,
Das heißt, sie haben einfach mal geguckt, befindet sich dieses Telefon, was hier gerade läuft, äh in Kupatino, dann äh machen wir einfach mal ein paar Sachen nicht. Dann werden diese ganzen Abis nicht gekollt so, aber sobald wir irgendwie in China sind, äh läuft der Hase halt schon wieder.
Solche Sachen haben sie dann halt irgendwie nachgewiesen, ne? Und auch das ist äh für die auch gar nichts Neues. Also sie haben sozusagen ohnehin noch so eine Technik, die diesen schönen Namen Grayballing,
trägt
Greyboarding ist so ein Mischwort aus Grey Listing, das kennt man so aus dem E-Mail-Bereich, wo man sagt, so ja, wir lassen dich im Prinzip mal ran, aber wir verzögern mal die Annahme der E-Mail und wenn du ein Spammer bist oder dann bist du von uns wahrscheinlich schon genervt, weil du willst ja deinen Scheiß schnell loswerden. Dann wenn das eine legitime Mail ist, so, dann dann rufst du halt noch dreimal an, das ist so wie
dich ruft jemand an und dann so, ja, wenn's wichtig ist, wird der normal anrufen. So.
Wenn wir nie tun.
Machst du halt so beim fünften Mal gehst du dann ran, so, ja okay, meinetwegen. Ja, Grey Listing steckt da drin und Eyeboarling, also quasi so diese diese Software-Überwachung und das äh war dann wiederum von Uber.
In was heißt Eyeboarding.
Einfach äh einen dein Auge Apfel drauf werfen, also überwachen.
Okay, wir gucken, wer hier Organ.
Genau. Und äh beziehung. Und ähm.
Ja, das haben sie dann wiederum verwendet, um Polizisten und sonstige äh Überprüfungsbeamte zu erkennen, die halt U-Bahn, Dienste, Buchen, um halt Testfahrten zu machen. Und.
Um nachher zu gucken, ob die.
Die den Reglementierung entsprechen, ob die Autos irgendwie äh überhaupt den richtigen Zustand haben, um die Beförderungs äh Gegebenheiten, die gesetzlichen äh die lokal gelten um ne also so und das äh.
Haben Sie überhaupt 'n P-Schein.
Ja genau und es sind wohl so ein bisschen zu sehr aufm Schwein gegangen, da sind sie auf die geile Idee gekommen
dann dann bauen wir doch einfach äh mal eine Software ein, die in der Lage ist zu erkennen, dass es sich hier um einen Polizist oder einen Überprüfungsbeamten handelt. Fragt man sich natürlich auch, wie kommen sie denn darauf so? Und das Interessante ist, dass es wohl ein
Wie nennen sie das
Sie haben dann extra und das ist auch nicht nur bei Uber so, ja, das ist sozusagen mittlerweile auch äh sing äh in diesem ganzen E-Business. Es gibt ein kompetitiv
Intelligence Team. Frei übersetzt sozusagen ein äh Nachrichten äh Dienst für kapitalistische Vorteile äh,
dass ich quasi explizit darum gekümmert hat, auch die entsprechenden Informationen zu sammeln zu sammeln. Das heißt, sie sind dann losgegangen, haben die Beamten
ausspioniert, haben rausgefunden, wo ihre Büros sind und haben dann sozusagen auch an dieser Geobewegung und ähnlichen Meterdaten Kreditkartennummern
und so weiter, also.
Der Nummer hatten wir eben drüber gesprochen, auf dem iPhone schwierig in der Android-Welt sieht das ja nochmal ganz anders aus, ja? Also da da sind viele dieser Informationen und dieses Fingerprinting ist dort
viel einfacher, zumal auch noch so sehr viele sehr alte Versionen dort äh zum Einsatz kommen. Also das haben sie halt alles genommen,
und dann sozusagen festgestellt so, hm, der hier gerade ein Taxi bestellt.
Ist wohl gerade so ein mit der und der Wahrscheinlichkeit ein Überprüfungsbeamter und dann kam halt keins oder ihm wurden irgendwelche angezeigt, die irgendwo auf ihn warten, aber,
die es gar nicht gab und äh all solche Sachen, ne? Also so ein bisschen äh,
so diese Tarpet-Methode, ne, so wir lassen dich mal hier irgendwie in so ein Teerloch reinstapfen und da wirst du dich dann schon irgendwie festfahren, dann werden die anderen halt glücklich äh normale Leute befördern, äh bist du halt erstmal ausgeschaltet. Auch das
kam äh raus. Offizielle Sprachregelung bei U-Bahn natürlich
Ja, das ist ja total wichtig, diese Funktion zu haben, weil wir müssen ja unsere Fahrer beschützen, weil es wohl doch das kann ich mir ganz gut vorstellen, teilweise in manchen Ländern auch so Aufruhr gegeben hat
so Taxiunternehmen und andere Beförderungs äh Dienstleister
einfach total den Hass auf diese Uhrausbeutung hatten und dann äh quasi so Mops losgeschickt haben, die dann einfach Oberfahrer äh äh attackiert haben, also denen da richtig mit Gewalt äh ähm und anderen äh Dingen gedroht haben, keine Ahnung, was da jetzt konkret abgelaufen ist, so ob ich das jetzt gelesen
ja um die sozusagen einzuschüchtern, also nach dem Motto,
Uwe, ihr nicht mehr rum, sondern äh hat sich ausgeobert und äh ja, ist oder unser Turf. Also, so Mafia, Digital, das ist äh hier offensichtlich, ne? So schönes Obertaxi haben sie da. Also.
Solche Nummern und was äh dieses Kompetitive Intelligence Team wohl auch äh gemacht hat, ist, dass sie tatsächlich so in äh
rumgelaufen sind, sich angeguckt haben, was sind da gerade so die billigsten Telefone sind, die im Verkauf sind? Haben sich dann die Nummern äh notiert, also das ist die
Identifikationsnummer der der Telefone, die ja dann auch, sagen wir mal, immer in so gewissen Ranges ausgegeben wird, also hast du eine Nummer, hast du halt unter Umständen auch so einen kompletten Nummernblock,
so weißt du, ah, das sind jetzt hier so die billigen
Telefone, Duschour und die haben sie dann einfach mal komplett ausgesperrt, um einfach zu verhindern, dass die Beamten oder andere Gruppen sich einfach massenhaft die billigsten Telefone kaufen, um dann eben in massiver äh Angriffsformation mit möglichst vielen Telefonen gleichzeitig da irgendwie Betrug zu machen oder eben auch ausspielen inzwischen. Also es ist ein
ein ein, den man sich irgendwie fast gar nicht vorstellen kann,
Was hat am Schluss dieser ganzen Debatte, das ging im Netz natürlich dann hin und her und inwiefern ist denn jetzt hier die Security von vom iPhone ein Problem oder was hat Uber jetzt wirklich gemacht? Kann da auch noch so Sachen raus, das äh Uba sich unter anderem dann auch,
bei Party äh Intelligence Dienstleistern, also man merkt schon so Nachrichtendiensttätigkeit ist mittlerweile einfach auch Business, ja? Da gibt's so eine Firma, die heißt Slice Intelligence und ähm.
Die hat einen Dienst betrieben, der hieß an Rollme, der erstmal sehr kundenfreundlich äh rüberkommt. Das ist so wir helfen dir,
lästige Dienste loszuwerden, für die, die dich irgendwann mal subscribed hast, aber wo du irgendwie überhaupt nicht mehr weißt, dass du da jetzt überhaupt einen Account hast und du willst den ganzen Scheiß irgendwie loswerden an Rolme. So und dann haben Leute sich das irgendwie geklickt und dann haben die irgendwie äh,
quasi Zugriff erhalten auf ihre Mailbox. So nach dem Motto, ja, schau doch mal durch meine Mail
Was da so für Bestätigungsemail, Receads, tralala und so weiter sind.
Haben dann sozusagen eine Liste daraus generiert, mit hier sind die Abmeldelinks für die ganzen Dienste, wo du offenbar mal einen Account gemacht hast oder dich auf andere Art und Weise angemeldet hast und dann kannst du halt schön raus, so. Kostenloser Dienst, aber wie das immer so ist, mit
kostenlosen Diensten, hat natürlich auch einen Pferdefuß, der Pferdefuß in dem Moment, dass die.
Angeblich anonymisierten Daten, dann wiederum natürlich schön äh als Usit Szenario weiterverkauft werden und dann halt gerade so Anbiet äh Nutzer von Lift und also ein konkurrieren mit Uber konkurrierenden äh Dienst
Unter anderem ähm dann quasi so als Datenwolke angeboten werden zum Kauf und da hat sich natürlich dann Uber auch bedient
um dort halt wiederum auch ein Fingerprinting unter Umständen zu unterstützen, das ist jetzt so der Bereich der Spekulation. Ich höre an dieser Stelle auch auf, weil es wird schon klar, äh
Das ist wirklich ein scheißer Haufen, der, der, der, der, der, der riecht wirklich noch zehn Meilen gegen den Wind und
Abgesehen davon, dass diese Firma einfach ein äh unerträglichen, unakzeptablen Umgang schon mit den eigenen Mitarbeitern pflegt, äh von den Fahrern und letztlich auch den Kunden ähm
übersteigt wirklich das Ausmaß der Vorstellungskraft bei weitem.
Das sind also so von denen hörst du echt nichts Positives, ne? Also sind halt einfach Arschlöcher.
Ja. Wirft natürlich auch nochmal, wenn ich das nochmal aufbringen darf, auch nochmal so ein Licht auf diese ganze Frage mit wie geschlossen müssen eigentlich solche Stores sein, ja,
man hat immer diese Abwägung zwischen offen im Sinne von.
Marktmacht kann nicht ausgenutzt werden. Jeder hat die Möglichkeit einem Markt beizutreten und und und dort gleichberechtigt, mehr oder weniger gleichberechtigt äh am gesamten wirtschaftlichen Geschehen teilzunehmen oder eben auch nur,
Zugriff auf das eigene Gerät, natürlich auch nochmal so ein Aspekt. Auf der anderen Seite hast du natürlich diesen Security-Aspekt, der halt einerseits ein,
Technische Security ist, wie sie ja hier auch, durchscheint, ne, Zugriff auf identifizierende Merkmale et cetera, aber eben auch so dieses
was passiert, wenn jetzt äh App Anbieter halt Rogue gehen und einfach.
Sich Schemata ausdenken, die jetzt durch so einen technischen Prozess so auch gar nicht mehr abzufangen sind, weil das einfach eine,
Plexe Gesamtmaterie ist und ein Gesamtverhalten äh sich da abbildet, wo man einfach dann irgendwann sagt, hör mal, was ihr da macht, ist einfach nicht mehr im Interesse unserer Kunden,
und wir drehen euch jetzt den Hahn ab und wir können euch halt auch den Hahn abdrehen, weil,
das erlaubt halt unser System, ne? Und ja, das ist immer eine schwierige Abwägung in dieser ganzen äh Debatte, mit was denn jetzt gerade mal wieder böse ist oder so. Äh man sieht, dass Security.
Marktkontrolle.
Schutzprivatsphäre oder auch Schutz im weiteren Sinne sozusagen von Leuten ähm ja alles so Dinge sind, die stark,
Ineinander greifen und dass es sehr schwierig ist klare Aussagen darüber zu fällen, was ist jetzt hier irgendwie evel oder nicht.
Weil wir jetzt natürlich schon sagen muss, dass das, was,
Uber da getan hat, zu versuch einen Weg zu finden, Geräte zu identifizieren und irgendwie nach bestimmten Kunden zu suchen. Ähm
heißt halt nicht, dass ihr die U-Bahn-App hattet, sie deinstalliert und Uwe euch weiterhin getrackt hat, wo ihr hingeht, ne? Also das muss man schon auch irgendwie mal,
andere Ebene von Mistbau und ähm in der Android-Welt hättest du das wahrscheinlich so gar nicht
gehabt, weil dich Android wahrscheinlich gar nicht so wirklich die Zielsetzung hat, dich vor vor einem der so zum Judi äh Fingerprinting-Impf zu schützen. Ich weiß ich nicht genau, gehe ich
einig.
Also ich verfolge das nicht so genau natürlich, aber eine Anriedwelt gibt's natürlich auch, Release um Release,
immer weitere Schritte von Google ähm Dinge dort auch dicht zu machen und auch der App Store wird sicherlich seinen Teil dazu beitragen. Aber hier sind halt zwei Probleme. Erstens.
Traditionell hat das immer sehr lange gedauert und da waren sie immer Late to the Game auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite hast du halt so einen Wildwuchs,
der Anrüd wählt, wo halt einerseits fünfundachtzig Prozent der Leute überhaupt keine aktuelle Software haben, teilweise gar keine Software-Updates bekommen
und ähm was dazu noch kommt, dadurch, dass man eben im Prinzip ein Anführungsstrichen offenes System hat, das natürlich auch andere App Stores äh mitgenutzt werden von anderen Anbietern, werden Telefone verkauft, die den Google Playstore vielleicht gar nicht haben oder nur als zweite Option et cetera, pip.
Schaffst es da nicht so ein Wächter zu machen, ne, wenn du selbst wenn du jetzt Google anfängst im Playstore darauf zu achten, dann äh verklopfst du die Dinger halt noch durch irgendwie zwanzig andere Stores, wo keiner mehr drauf guckt.
Und da gibt's dann äh nicht so viel Overside, weil die natürlich wiederum primär eigentlich ein Interesse daran haben, so viele Verkäufe zu tätigen, wie irgendwie und bei Apple ist das halt ein Aspekt, aber der andere Aspekt ist halt, na ja, aber wir wollen halt auch unsere Userbase irgendwie äh schützen, weil.
Würde aber jetzt auch, ich würde jetzt aber irgendwie Apple auch nicht irgendwie groß als irgendwie ja die wollen ihre Nutzer schützen, ich mein keine Ahnung, die haben halt das war halt ein Verstoß gegen gegen Richtlinien und man sieht auch Apples Rolle hier, ich meine ja klar, dass dann das Tim guckt dann mit diesem.
Ne, die wollten sie, ne, auch sie wollen nur ihr Businessmodell schützen natürlich, aber.
Genau, aber jeder andere wird,
jeder andere wird bei Verstoß einfach rausgeworfen. Also ich sehe da jetzt ähm ich sehe da jetzt Tim guck auch nicht als den weißen Ritter, äh der uns alle vor dem gemeinen Ubertracking geschützt hat, sondern der hat halt einfach gesagt, pass mal auf. Ähm
Du benutzt da, du machst dein Api-Call und du versuchst unseren Prüfprozess äh zu verarschen. Äh lasset äh lasset dir gesagt sein. So und das ähm sehe ich jetzt im eher im Rahmen einer.
Auseinandersetzung zwischen Silicon Well Valley Giganten.
Ich wollte hier in äh kein kein reinwaschen, ich habe ja auch nur gesagt, es ist einfach schwierig,
hier eine klare Forderung auch zu stellen, wie so etwas zu sein hat, weil du halt immer das Problem hast
in dem Moment, wo du etwas nicht dicht machst
du halt damit auch Dinge öffnest, die einfach auch überhaupt null wünschenswert sind und und da ist glaube ich auch noch keine wirkliche Lösung in Sicht,
eine technische, wirtschaftliche gesellschaftliche Gesamtkomplexität, wo wir glaube ich noch einige Jahre drüber diskutieren werden. Aber jetzt nicht mehr in dieser Sendung.
Richtig, denn jetzt diskutieren wir über Personalausweise und Aufenthaltstitel.
So so. Was ist da denn passiert.
Ach ja, also das ist ja auch eine eine lange und schmerzhafte Geschichte zweitausend ähm sieben kam, glaube ich, der elektronische.
Personalausweis, früher schon, ich glaube ähm zweitausendfünf oder sowas ging's äh ging's in wurde erstens, wurde es zunächst diskutiert für die Einführung in Pässe und ähm.
Irgendwie hat das ja nie so wirklich abgehoben. Ich habe ja vor zwei Folgen, glaube ich, schon mal davon gesprochen. Es gibt eben diese diese Passauslesefunktion, ne? Das steht irgendwie vorne, auf dem Pass steht in dem,
M äh RZ Machine Redable Zone, die Nummer, mit der du wieder mit der du dann quasi eine,
automatisch die Passdaten auslesen kannst und äh dann zum Beispiel an den großen Drehkreuzflughäfen in Deutschland durch diese schnell durch diese Schnellpassanlagen gehst, wo dann nochmal äh eine eine Anlage so ein biometrisches Foto von dir macht und dich abgleicht und dadurch eben diesen
Passkontrollausreiseprozess irgendwie äh beschleunigen soll.
Ähm darf da sieht man also eine Anwendung von,
von diesen Dingern, ja? Also es kamen diese Chips in die in die Pässe rein und es gibt eine es gibt exakt ein,
Anwendungsfall, wo man denen begegnet und den auch nicht an jedem Flughafen, sondern in Deutschland habe kenne ich die an zweien, eben sinnvollerweise halt an den Flughäfen, wo du auch wirklich massiv aus und Einreise hast.
Ähm dann.
Kammer, auf die die ja wäre ja auch voll geil. Ähm diese diese Funktionalität in ähm den Personalausweis einzubauen.
Also nennt sich dann äh EID, das heißt, du musst irgendwo deinen Ausweis zeigen und dann wäre es doch super cool, wenn man den nicht mehr abtippen muss, sondern quasi die Ausweisdaten einfach mal kurz so,
mit dem mit dem RFID Leser auslesen kann.
Und ähm das ist jetzt in einer in einer Situation, wo du vor Ort bist, noch so,
halb wichtig, ne? Also ist da eine eine minimale Komforterhöhung sagen wir mal, du,
schließt irgendein Mobilfunkvertrag ab. Ähm ne, dann musst du da nicht irgendwie alles vorlesen und wie schreibt man äh hier die Straße oder wie ähm.
Shodowieski mit Y oder A, ne?
Thermi. Ähm.
Da ist das noch so mittel, sinnvoll, interessant wird das aber natürlich, wenn du sagst, wie ist das denn hier im E-Commerce, ne?
Bis zu achtzehn darfst du auf die Pornoseite oder nicht, halt mal dein,
Perso an die an das an das Lesegerät, was du dir für fünfzig Euro neben deinem Computer gestellt hast. Aber auch da wird's natürlich dann wieder spannender, technologische Entwicklung, RFID,
Lesegeräte oder heißt jetzt eher NFC, ähm, NFC,
Sensoren und Reader sind in den meisten Mobiltelefonen drin. Apple hat die äh API dafür zum Beispiel noch nicht freigegeben, aber äh eingebaut ist es.
Ich glaube, hat ihn noch nicht freigegeben. Ich weiß nicht.
Nee, haben sie nicht und auch da argumentieren sie unter anderem mit Sicherheit.
Ja, verständlicherweise, ne? Wenn du so ein Android-Telefon hast, hast du, kannst du schöne äh NFC-Scanner haben äh und äh Kreditkarten auslesen, iPhone halt nicht. Dafür musst du dir dann halt eine Android holen, ne? Also hat diese Offenheit halt eben auch.
Große Vorteile im im Hacksport. Gut, dann.
In Deutschland sagt man also ja, der, dann wollen wir doch mal dieses EID machen und ähm wo eingeführt wurde, dass vor vor sieben Jahren diese neuen äh Personalausweise.
Ähm die eben unter anderem diese Funktionalität haben und einiges kann eben nach Eingabe des Codes, der auf dem Ding steht
ausgelesen werden, anderes kann andere Operationen müssen mit einer mit einer Geheimpin ausgegeben werden. Und jetzt hat man festgestellt das war ja irgendwie eine ganz schön teurer Spaß den Leuten, dass diese Funktionalität zu geben,
Und irgendwie, wenn wir die darüber aufklären, dass sie das auch deaktivieren können, ähm dann machen die das
Und das ist ja blöd, ne, weil äh eigentlich wollen wir ja, dass es dieses E-ID gibt und weil ähm nur weil nur irgendwie ein geringer Anteil der Menschen dieses EID überhaupt aktiviert hat.
Ähm.
Also nämlich fünfzehn Prozent, also zweieinhalb Millionen Bürger von irgendwie äh einundfünfzig Millionen, die irgendwie seit zweitausendzehn so einen äh neuen Ausweis bekommen haben. Ähm.
Ach so, nee, fünfzehn Prozent haben das schon mal genutzt. Ein Drittel, genauso was, ein Drittel hat das überhaupt freigeschaltet, das heißt, zwei Drittel sagen, was Funkchip in meinem Watt, nee, lass weg, mach aus, ne? Tschüss. So und von dem Drittel, wie gesagt.
Die Regierung will uns mit ihren Wellen steuern.
Und von dem Drittel, die das Ding haben, ähm bleiben dann am Ende zweieinhalb Millionen Bürger, die die Funktion schon mal genutzt haben, ja? Und das ist natürlich ein relativ ähm trauriges Fazit einer Aktion.
Die die hier über sieben Jahre läuft und sich nicht durchsetzen könnte. Also was macht man? Man denkt sich, ja das muss sich ändern. Wir müssen Anreize bieten,
dass die Menschen das nutzen. Und das tun wir am besten, indem wir ähm die Option, das wegzuschalten,
entfernen, das heißt du in Zukunft gibt es diese Möglichkeit nicht mehr dem zu widersprechen
Und ähm weitere Einsparungsmöglichkeiten hat man entdeckt, indem man einen die Menschen auch nicht mehr sinnvoll darüber aufklärt, was da gemacht wird, sondern es den Ämtern überlässt und nicht mehr sagt, hier haben sie eine Broschüre oder sowas
sondern,
Wir machen das einfach mal und äh wir können ja online irgendwo ein bisschen Info dazu vergraben, dass das alles ungefährlich ist.
Ähm das.
Ist natürlich jetzt nicht eine vertrauensbildende Maßnahme und wird im Zweifelsfall dazu führen, dass die Menschen sich daran erinnern, was wir vor zwei Sendungen besprochen haben mit den Induktionsherden, äh dass ein,
kurzes, ein, ein achtloses, vergessen des Personalausweises auf der Induktionsheadplatte ähm,
relativ schnell dazu führen kann, dass ein kleiner Puls diese EID-Funktion eben dauerhaft deaktiviert.
Ähm dieses Gesetz ähm das eher das neue EID-Gesetz wurde also jetzt äh am am neunzehnten,
Nähe die Anhörung war später. Ähm da war glaube ich bei unserer Stellungnahme ein bisschen gefudelt, wann wir die formuliert haben. Die Anhörung war am vierundzwanzigsten April und ähm
Der CCC hat dazu eine Stellungnahme eingereicht, verfasst von ähm Hauptautorin Constanze Kurz, ähm Mitarbeit, äh, Jan Kristler, Linus Neumann, Frank Rieger. Ähm,
Konstanze war auch am Montag bei der Anhörung und hat dann so ein bisschen ähm ein bisschen äh unsere Kritik an dieser zwangsweisen.
Einführung vertreten, dass das ja nun wirklich nicht die Vertrauensbildende Maßnahme sein kann. Wir haben wurden außerdem gefragt, was es so für andere,
Verfahren gibt, die äh zu einer sicheren äh Identifizierung oder Authentifizierung in diesen Fällen äh genutzt werden könnten, denn dieses E-ID-Verfahren ist ja mal wieder ein schöner deutscher Alleingang.
Ähm das ist der, der deutsche äh deutsche EID mit irgendwie Lesegerät und Ausweissoftware in Java und haste alles nicht gesehen,
und wenn du dann da irgendwie im Ausland bist, dann geht stößt du halt schnell an seine Grenzen. Entsprechend haben wir mal darauf hingewiesen, dass es.
Entsprechende international standardisierte Verfahren gibt. Ähm die GSMA haben wir da als Beispiel genannt, also die äh.
Manchmal Global System, offenbar bei Communications, äh Social Ation, krass, ich weiß nicht mehr, was GSM heißt. Äh.
Es hängt ja immer davon ab, wann man's auf Französisch oder auf Englisch äh.
GSMA ist quasi die die Organisation, die Mobilfunkstandards definiert und und herausgibt und mit denen man eben über sich über die über das Fortschreiten des Mobilfunkes und oder das nicht Fortschreiten des Mobilfunkes,
redet. Die haben da so einen Standard für ähm für Identifikation, bei der die SIM-Karte der Vertrauensanker ist,
du das Auslesen eben über die schönen NFC-Chips machst, ja? Ist ja auch eine, ist ja auch eine elegante Möglichkeit ähm das so zu tun
ist international standardisiert, kann also überall Anwendungen finden
feiner, granulierter äh ein ein granulares Rechtekonzept zu sagen, okay, diese Art von Anfrage machen wir ohne Pin-Abfrage, diese machen wir mit Pin-Up-Frage, aber dann auch nur
die Stadt und nicht die Adresse, also die haben da so ein haben da auf jeden Fall einen ganz schönen Standard, der natürlich jetzt in der Privat in der Privatwirtschaft dann eher Verwendung findet, was jetzt nicht heißen soll, dass wir sagen.
Ans Telefon gebunden ist wiederum.
An diesem Karte, na ja, aber das Telefon hast du halt eher vor äh dabei als äh einen Ausweis, ne? Hättest halt ein Gerät weniger, du kanntest dann auch zum Beispiel von Apps
direkt darauf zugreifen auf die SIM-Karte, ne? Müsstest nicht immer deinen Ausweis da dran halten, was, also wir haben einfach nur darauf hingewiesen, dass es eben auch andere
International stand der Disierteverfahren gibt, deren Anwendung ähm gewisse Vorteile hatte. Da wurden wir aber auch nach ähm.
Da wurden wir eben auch spezifisch nachgefragt. Weiteres Problem äh betrifft die Anbieter, denn um diese, um quasi über so einen E-ID-Reader, so eine eine Abfrage zu machen.
Ähm bräuchtest du,
brauchst du ein Zertifikat, das dich zum Auslesen zur Nutzung dieser Funktion berechtigt als Anbieter. Und da ähm das haben sehr wenige Leute,
bisher beantragt, irgendwie zweihundert noch was oder sowas, ne? Ähm,
Und das hat die Bundesregierung sich natürlich auch gedacht, ja wie können wir denn einen Anreiz schaffen, ähm dass die Leute, die, dass die Leute mehr so Ausleserzertifikate bei uns beantragen? Ah ja genau, wir machen den Prüfprozess einfacher und geben die einfach raus wie
wie warme Semmeln, ja? Äh auch das natürlich irgendwie ähm nicht besonders cool, weil das
Am Ende dazu führen wird, dass du äh dass du diese Eidie am am Ende
inflationär verwendest, ne? Sie wollen also im Prinzip dafür sorgen, dass jeder das irgendwie machen kann und man überall mal eben seinen Ausweis dranhält und das führt natürlich zu einer,
über Identifizierung, dass dass du einfach an in einfach überall auf einmal dein Ausweisdokument dranhältst, was du ja heute aus gutem Grunde nur in den seltenen Fällen tust, wo das wirklich mal notwendig ist,
Also keine Ahnung Zutritt zum Deutschen Bundestag, Beantragung eines Passes,
Was weiß ich, auf dem Boden liegende in der Polizeikontrolle, ne? Das sind so die drei, das sind so die drei Momente, wo du dein Personalausweis brauchst, ne.
Ja, können Sie sich ausweisen? Ja, wieso kann man das jetzt schon alleine.
Sehr schön. Ähm.
Entschuldige mich. Jetzt schon. Bei wem auch immer. Aber ich fand den immer lustig.
Also die bauen hier eigentlich im Prinzip alle möglichen Sperren
alle möglichen Bürger und Verbraucherschutzgeschichten, die sie vorher hatten, haben halt gesagt, ah, das ist irgendwie sperrig, das das hindert uns an der Einführung und der, an der Verbreitung dieses Verfahrens und das bauen wir jetzt einfach erstmal ab, weil dadurch können wir das Vertrauen bestimmt
ausweiten, wenn schon jetzt zwei Drittel der Bevölkerung das nicht haben wollen, dann werden die es bestimmt voll geil finden, wenn wir es ihnen einfach aufzwingen und nicht mehr sagen, was das was die Risiken sind. Ne, die Risiken lasse ich jetzt mal ähm gezielt außen vor, denn das ist
Wie sagt man so schön? Kanonisch. Könnte auch mal ein Wort nachlesen. Äh.
Ein sogenanntes WCP.
Ähm ich will aber auch dazu sagen, ich meine.
Auf in auf wenige Arten anderen.
Wegen der Implementierung, kann man mit so einer Smartcard echt coole Dinge machen. Und es kommt immer darauf an, was man so für ähm welche Funktionalitäten man denn in diese Smartkarten,
einbauen möchte. Ähm ich habe damals bei meiner Stellungnahme für das äh für das E-Government Gesetz gesagt. Hör mal, ihr könntet doch auch echt so ein richtig schönes S-Mann-Zertifikat,
auf den auf den Eper so machen.
Mal korrekte DE-Mail.
Und schon gäb's mal korrekte Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte äh E-Mails mit ähm
sicher verwahrten Schlüsseln, die noch nicht mal ihr auslesen könnt und geschweige denn irgendjemand anders und die man irgendwie zerstören kann und so, es wäre ist echt cool, ne? Also ähm als als Vertrauensanker für verschlüsselte E-Mails sind so Smart Cuts
immer noch das Beste, was du haben kannst, ne? Du willst eigentlich deinen Key gar nicht auf dem Device haben? Und da bist du gut beraten, den auf so einer Smartcard zu haben,
die die ähm Elitehacker weltweit äh äh nutzen, Smart Cuts zur Aufbewahrung, der ähm der wichtigsten,
wichtigsten Keymaterials so. Das wäre eine super cool.
Bitcoins.
Ne, da kannst du viel drauf machen, wäre alles super, wer also ist halt
Hardwaresecurity nicht mehr irgendwelche Softwarefuh, sondern das ist nochmal eben eine andere Ebene. Ähm auch da gibt's natürlich wiederum Angriffe und sowas, aber da bist du schon auf einer ganz anderen Ebene und es wäre echt mal geil gewesen, wenn jetzt fünfzig Millionen ähm
Bürger in dieser Zeit die Gelegenheit bekommen hätten ähm quasi,
'ne verbriefte Identität zu haben, die der, die du bei der,
vom Bürgeramt oder wo auch immer du dir deinen deinen Ausweis holst, ähm verbrieft hast, dass du weißt, wenn ich jetzt an diesen Schlüssel verschlüsse, ja? Der ähm.
Der gehört wirklich Max Mustermann. Ja?
Und ähm der ist so gut wie ausgeschlossen, dass jemand anderes Zugriff drauf hat oder nach den besten Möglichkeiten ausgeschlossen. Man könnte damit auch coole Sachen machen, aber stattdessen
macht man halt so ein, so einen halb gehangenen nationalen Alleingang, der an dem wieder keiner Spaß hat und macht, bricht am Ende alle möglichen
ähm vertrauensbildende Maßnahmen ab, weil man gemerkt hat, ähm das ist nicht gelungen. Wir müssen es den Leuten jetzt einfach zwangsweise über helfen, ja.
Weiterhin, wie das immer so ist, kann man in seinem Gesetzentwurf natürlich so ein paar andere Sachen unterbringen, zum Beispiel ähm sagt man, ab jetzt dürfen dann die, nicht ab jetzt, Entschuldigung, das ist ein Fehler. Ab zweitausendfünfundzwanzig, zweitausendeinundzwanzig
dürfen dann die Geheimdienste.
Auf unsere auf die äh Daten, die wir dabei gesammelt haben, nämlich die biometrischen äh Ausweisdaten zugreifen. Ja.
Schon heute stehen nämlich die digitalisierten Pass- und Ausweisbilder der Polizei zum automatisierten Abrauf zur Verfügung. Und ähm jetzt sollen das bitte auch ähm
Die Geheimdienste äh dürfen. Zwar erst ab ab äh zwanzig einundzwanzig ähm und kriegen dann also einen unmittelbaren geheimdienstlichen Zugriff auf die Daten in den Meldeämtern.
Ja, so lange brauchen sie wahrscheinlich noch, um die passenden Datenbanken aufzubauen.
Na ja und die Protokollierung des Zugriffs ähm erfolgt natürlich auf Seiten der Geheimdienste. Und nicht auf Seiten der Meldeämter ist der Geheimdienst, ne?
Ja
So, das heißt ähm du du liest irgendwie dir so diesen Gesetzesentwurf Entwurf durch und denkst dir vielleicht, okay, Eidi hin oder her und am Ende steht halt dann irgendwie drin, ja, alles klar, ne, mehr oder weniger äh bauen wir ähm eine.
Dieses schöne ähm Biometriedatenbank mit Vollzugriff der Geheimdienste noch nebenbei steht auf Seite Hasse nicht.
Über welche Informationen können sie denn dann abfragen.
Na, ähm also die, die das ursprüngliche war ja, dass diese Daten gar nicht digital aufbewahrt werden sollen. Das hat sich geändert und ähm jetzt muss ich natürlich gerade, ich ich habe gerade nur die,
Nee, ich habe die Stellung am Name auf, aber ich habe hier auf dem Desktop natürlich noch die ähm.
Den Gesetzesentwurf liegen, ähm, der, der tatsächlich, äh, also es wie der ist auch wieder als DIV geschrieben, ne? Artikel zwei weitere Änderungen des Personalausweises ausgeweis ausgesetztes zum ersten Mai zwanzig einundzwanzig,
Paragraph fünfundzwanzig Absatz zwei des Personalausweisgesetzes vom achtzehnten Juni zweitausendneun, das zuletzt durch Artikel eins dieses Gesetzes geändert worden ist, wird wie folgt geändert. Das ist schön, weil zuletzt sich Artikel eins dieses Gesetzes ist, damit ist genau dieses,
Blatt Papier gemeint, was du gerade liest, aber die Änderung ist ja erst zum zwanzigsten zum zweitausend.
Einundzwanzig, das heißt du hast ein Dis mit noch Dimension Zeit aber OK.
Nach dem Motto irgendwie keiner, keiner muss Angst haben und dann steht irgendwo unten so und in drei Jahren fügen wir noch einen nicht in diesem Satz ein.
Äh in Satz eins werden die Wörter Polizei untergestrichen.
Nach Satz zwei wird folgender Satz eingefügt. Die Polizisten des Bundes und der Länder. Das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, der militärische Abschärmdienst, der Bundesnachrichtendienst sowie die Verfassungsschutzbehörden der Länder dürfen das Lichtbild,
zur Erfüllung ihrer Aufgaben im automatisierten Verfahren abrufen.
Zack. Super.
Ja ähm das Gleiche, die gleiche Änderung, gleicher Satz ähm im Passgesetz,
ne? Parallel dazu in Paragraph äh zweiundzwanzig Absatz zwei Passgesetz und ähm.
Begründet wird das Ganze mit Personalausweise und.
Pässe werden häufig nicht am Wohnort der Personen ausgestellt. Die Ermittlungen der zuständigen Behörde ist daher zeitaufwendig. In zeitkritischen Situationen steht aber eine solche Zeitspanne nicht zur Verfügung. Dies gilt, wenn zum Beispiel zur einwandfreien Identifizierung ein Lichtbild
erforderlich ist. Die örtlich zuständige Behörde, die den Pass oder Personalausweis ausgestellt hat, ist aber aufgrund des häufigen Umzugs der Person,
nicht bekannt. Eine Abfrage der in Betracht kommenden Stellen auf manuellen Weg scheidet aus, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, die Zentralität ist uns alles zu kompliziert, wir machen einfach eine zentrale Biometriedatenbank.
Und speichern das alles auf Vorrat.
Geht da schwuppdiwupp und dann haben wir eine ähm tatsächlich und wir mussten es auch mehrmals lesen. Ja, eine Zentrale äh Datenbank mit den mit den biometrischen Bildern.
Ich halte das für eine besonders äh schlechte Idee, weiterheiters heißt es in der Begründung, der automatisierte Abruf ist zugleich die schnellere Form der Kommunikation. Ja, richtig.
Verwaltungsaufwand reduzieren ja.
Ja genau, Lean Management, damit machen wir den der Start wird äh schlanker indem er sich mehr Daten anfri.
Also es ist wirklich, ja, ist wirklich skurril, skurril, ja?
Säuft's.
Und da wir sind eben dahin gekommen von einem Punkt, wo wo irgendwann mal behauptet wurde oder wo irgendwann einmal der Stand war. Die werden überhaupt nicht gespeichert, ne? Dann würden die irgendwann digital und dann, ja und dann irgendwie, ja, wir lassen die mal dezentral an der Behörde liegen. Ja und was sie jetzt haben wollen, ist eben,
ähm eine zentrale Datenbank der der Lichtbilder.
Wird nicht mehr lange dauern und die äh DNA-Analyse dann auch noch auf dem auf dem Schein.
Also der der Zustand.
Sowas muss ich mich jetzt Musik beantragen, ja?
Der Zustand war bislang ähm war das nur per Anfrage oder in Ausnahmesituationen, etwa, wenn die Ausweisbehörde nicht erreichbar war möglich. Jede Anfrage wurde durch die Mail der Ämter protokolliert, die Geheimdienste konnten somit von dritten kontrolliert werden. All das fällt halt weg, ne?
Tja, und da hast du dann eben die äh die biometrischen Informationen eben auch mit drin,
Und das, mein lieber Tim, jetzt im Moment heißt es noch Lichtbild, aber bis zwanzigeinundzwanzig hast du noch viel Zeit. Ähm ne, mit mit dieser Fingerabdruckausgabe und so, das wäre doch super,
zur Ermittlung äh für die Strafverfolgungsbehörden werden wir einfach demnächst eine zentrale Datenbank mit allen Fingerabdrücken aller Menschen haben. Wäre doch spitze,
nie wieder,
lange suchen, ne? Dann du kennst das, wenn dann am Bildschirm die Finger abdrücke übereinander gehalten werden, weil der weil die CPU mit dem Vergleich noch nicht ausreicht, beschäftigt ist, die muss auch noch.
Muss auch noch schön Grafik und blinken und.
GPO langweilt sich.
Muss das nochmal ordentlich was draufgeworfen werden. Äh ja, so läuft's.
Ja
Na gut, dann haben wir ja jetzt äh zum zum Schluss auch nochmal so unseren äh dystopischen Klimax äh.
Hier haben wir nochmal einen historischen Klimax drin. Äh wie gesagt, die es gibt auch eine, glaube ich, eine, also ich habe das auf jeden Fall die Aufzeichnung im Stream geschaut. Es gibt sicherlich auch eine Videoaufzeichnung. Hm, wie Konstanze,
sich da.
Nur äußer, dann ist es auch irgendwie, also ist krass, ne? Bist du irgendwie denkst du dir so ach kleines Gesetz, aber auch mal wieder so. Dreizehn Seiten Stellungnahme, die da mal eben zusammengekommen sind.
Gut. Wir blicken nochmal ein wenig in die Welt.
Ja genau. Letzte Woche hatten wir über diese Shadow Broker Leaks gesprochen, wo also NSA vermeintliche NSA Zero Days,
sich plötzlich auf Gitter befunden haben und jetzt zum Einsatz durch,
durch die Bösen bereitstehen und wurde aber dann doch festgestellt, dass Microsoft schon vor dieser Veröffentlichung vier Wochen genau davor durch Zufall ähm genau diese Sachen dann gefixt hat.
Was eben hieß, dass ein auf dem aktuellen Stand befindliches System dann eben gegen diese Exploids nicht mehr,
für diese Exports nicht mehr empfänglich war. Wichtiger Punkt,
Natürlich geht es darum, welches System auf dem aktuellen Stand ist und äh das waren dann doch nicht viele und es haben dann ähm ein paar Leute mal äh gescannt, was mit dem
Explod Double Palsa, der glaube ich auf ähm SMB äh Server geht ähm.
So passiert und haben irgendwie gescannt und haben festgestellt, dass irgendwie zweihunderttausend Windows-Rechner in aller Welt da draußen schon damit infiziert wurden.
Äh mit anderen Worten. Die Leute haben also diese kritische SMB-Lücke, die zwar Mitte März mit dem Patch MS siebzehn null eins null äh geschlossen wurde, immer noch auf ihren Systemen und irgendwelche äh Scherzbeute,
rasieren jetzt eben gerade mit den NSA Exports durch Netz und haben sich mal eben zweihunderttausend Windows-Rechner geschnappt,
Das ist natürlich ärgerlich, aber sowas kommt von sowas, ne? Also wenn du irgendwie,
Wenn du deine Systeme nicht auf dem Patch Level hältst, dann passiert dir das eben, wenn kritische Windobilities geschlossen werden. Das wäre auch also.
Wahrscheinlich wäre es nicht so schnell und so in diesem Ausmaß passiert, wenn einfach nur die Sache gefixt worden wäre, aber
wenn Security-Patches kommen, dann sitzen halt auch Reverse Engineers da dran und gucken, was da wohl vorher die Wein Rebility war und bauen sich dann das Explore dazu. In diesem Fall war's halt nur einfacher, dass das Exploid da schon rumlag und man einfach nur noch sagen musste vor
IP in IP-Advers Range von IP for vier, du,
Exploid, and Own, ja? Also das war irgendwie relativ einfach und ist entsprechend auch geschehen.
Ja, also wenn wenn schon jemand darauf hinweist, dass du deinen Hosenlatz offen hast, dann sollst du vielleicht auch irgendwann mal am Reißverschluss ziehen, sonst äh zuckt der unter anderem jemand noch am Pullermann. Also das ist ja nun wirklich einfach.
Ja, scheiße, ist das, wenn du wenn da, na ja, okay. Wenn du, wenn man sowas mal vergisst, macht immer schön eure Updates.
Dann äh zu zum allgemeinen Erstaunen. Damit hätte ja keiner mehr gerechnet. Ähm.
Sitzt man im D-O Jay Department of Justice, der USA gerade und denkt sich, ach ey dieses Wiki League so, die könnten wir doch mal hops nehmen, lass uns doch mal schauen, was wir da vielleicht doch noch gegen die haben.
Und sammeln jetzt mal mögliche Anklagepunkte gegen Wiki Leagues und insbesondere natürlich dann äh Julian Assange. Darunter Verschwörungen, äh Diebstahl von ähm Regierungseigentum
Verletzung des S-Pionage-Acts und sagen, das ist aber noch nicht fertig, aber wir arbeiten daran und äh gucken mal, wenn wir das dann irgendwie zusammengestellt haben, dann bräuchten wir auch noch die,
Das im Provil von den höchsten Ebenen des Justizministeriums, aber die würden ja nicht daran arbeiten.
Wenn ähm die höchsten Ebenen des Sitzen des Justizministeriums.
Sagen würden, das lassen wir am Ende eh nicht durch. Und krass ist, dass es wir sind da genau an dieser äh,
An dieser Grenze zwischen Quellen, Schutz oder Anstiftung, denn Vicky liegt als solches, sind ja nun mal nur Publisher, die haben ja oder,
erhalten diese Daten und veröffentlichen die,
Spezifisch geht es hier um diese um die Manning Geschichten, ne? Also zweitausendzehn irgendwie die Cables und und auch dann natürlich gerade so ein bisschen um diese
CIA, äh, Exploid-Geschichten, aber sie kauen immer noch an dieser an den Manning Sachen rum.
Und da sagen sie halt so, ja, es gibt irgendwie, wir haben einen Beweis, dass äh Menning mit Assange,
gechattet hat über eine Technik, äh über eine Möglichkeit,
Passwort zu cracken, damit sich Manning nicht ähm mit ihrem äh eigenen Namen an einem Computer anmelden muss, wenn sie beginnt, diese Daten zu scraten,
Ja? Du willst ja nicht, du willst ja das dann quasi im System Log irgendwie keine Ahnung, ein Funktionsaccount steht,
nicht Private äh Menning und dann weißt du nämlich wo die Kajutte ist und gehst da vorbei.
Und offenbar mit anderen Worten, du, du schnappst dir die die Datei, wo die Passworthashis drinstehen auf dem Windows und fängst an, die zu cranken. Und du versuchst also, machst einen Blut vors Angriff oder sowas da drauf, ne?
Oder irgendetwas anderes. Vielleicht haben sie es auch mit einem äh mit einem Firewierer DMA-Angriff gemacht, aber auf jeden Fall gibt es einen Chat zwischen wohl äh,
wo? Ja wo Essangemielt äh wie man denn so ähm das bewerkstelligen könnte.
Weil davon versteht er ja auch was.
Davon versteht er was oder vielleicht zumindest andere, die ihn umgeben. Ähm.
Und jetzt sagen sie, nein, das könnte natürlich ähm als äh Beweismittel gegen Wiki Leags genutzt werden, dass sie hier äh angestiftet haben,
Und dass es sich um eine Verschwörung handelt von Wiki Leaks, dass sie sagen, hol uns mal diese Daten daraus und wir helfen dir dabei, äh wie du nicht erwischt wirst, hat er dann am Ende auch nicht ganz geklappt, aber ähm.
Ähm das wäre also eine eine feine Linie, die du als Journalist eben nicht überschreiten darfst.
Gleichzeitig äh bist du natürlich angehalten als Journalist äh Quellenschutz zu betreiben und äh die Frage ist also es geht da also quasi sehr, sehr ins Detail, ob man da am Ende einen Strick draus drehen kann oder nicht und ist dann eben
juristische Haarspalterei, aber interessant ist glaube ich insgesamt, dass die.
Dass das äh Justizministerium der USA sich da jetzt doch mal wieder ähm in Richtung des Assanges bewegt.
Dass obwohl Trump ja öffentlich bekannt hat, dass er doch wirklich liebt.
Ja
Ist vielleicht der Moment, wo man Angst bekommen sollte, wenn man betroffen ist. Weil ich dir mal vor irgendwie Trump verkündet seine Liebe zu dir, Linus würde ich ja auch die Beine in die Hand nehmen.
Es gibt übrigens kann ich an dieser Stelle noch empfehlen ein Interview mit äh Drean Assange, das glaube ich Jeremy Skay Hill, spricht er sich aus,
Ähm für die Intercep gemacht hat.
Oder teuer? Ja, doch das müsste Interset gewesen sein, gibt's also ein Interview mit Touri Assange, wo er auch,
dazu befragt wird, was denn, wie er denn so seine Rolle in dieser Trump-Geschichte bewertet. Und ich meine, die Position, die aus Horst da vertritt zu seiner eigenen Rolle ist net oder zu der Rolle von WikiLeaks, ist natürlich klar, sagt hier, wir haben
Daten bekommen, wir sagen wir veröffentlichen die, wir haben die geprüft, wir haben sie veröffentlicht, man kann sich auch nicht immer ausdenken und überlegen, wann man das macht.
Und wir machen so schnell wie möglich und entsprechend haben wir das eben bei Halloween Clinton auch gemacht, also er wäscht da seine Hände
sehr in Unschuld und Jeremy sagt dann auch an einigen Stellen irgendwie so Kammer und Julien aber das kann man sich mal anhören wenn man sich wenn man mal aus erster äh.
Anhören, also es ist als Podcast äh.
Ist ein Podcast, ja. Gibt's auch was schriftlich, also wer lieber äh ein anderthalbstündiges Gespräch oder sowas ähm liest, der äh darf das auch tun.
Na ja unsere Hörer und Hörerinnen, du weißt ja.
Lesen nebenbei während sie von uns hören, was anderes.
Dann gibt's noch neues Neues von den Fake News und dem Hate Street. Ähm.
Gibt's einen sehr schönen Artikel von Friedhelm Geis auf Golem DE, der äh mal bei dem Bundesjustizministerium angefragt hat und sagte, gebt uns doch mal bitte ein Beispiel für eine strafbare Falschnachricht,
die ihr mit eurem Netzwerk durchsetzungsgesetzt bekämpfen wollt. Ne, ist ja ein schönes, das ist ja wirklich und das Justizministerium,
so ne, der der Gesetzesentwurf sagt ja am Anfang, nach den Erfahrungen im US-Wahlkampf an, hat auch in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland die Bekämpfung von strafbaren Falschnachrichten in Klammern Fake News in sozialen Netzwerken
Priorität gewonnen, das ist der Einleitungssatz zum Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz. Und ähm.
Der der Antwort des des ähm des BMJ ist
das über die Erfahrung amerikanischer Politiker im US-Wahlkampf hinaus auch in Deutschland die Bekämpfung strafbarer Falschnachrichten an Bedeutung gewonnen hat, lässt sich schon anhand der allgemeinen Presseberichterstattung der vergangenen Monate
nachvollziehen. Und Friedhelm Geist sagt ja als klassischer Zirkel Zirkelschluss, die Medien berichten,
Weil die Parteien im Panikmodus das Thema auf die Tagesordnung gesetzt haben. Ja, also ähm und er bemängelt also äh dass es keine.
Dass das Bundesjustizministerium nicht in der Lage ist, auch nur einen einzigen empirischen Punkt,
Für das zu, auf für das zu zeigen, womit sie gerade zu tun haben. Weiterhin führt er aus. Ähm es gibt diesen Fall Lisa, ne? Das war, wenn ich das richtig erinnere ähm,
die Behauptung, dass da eine äh Frau von ähm von ähm Asylbewerbern im Zweifelsfall irgendwie belästigt oder vergewaltigt wurde, ne? Wenn ich das ähm.
Wenn ich das richtig äh in Erinnerung habe, frei erfundene Geschichte und ähm er stellt also fest.
Dass eine ähm also der ein Martin, der ein Anwalt, Martin Judle, der die Strafanzeige gestellt hatte, sagt
Eine bloße, nicht in Tatsachen, entsprechende Berichterstattung, allein ohne entsprechende Aussagen im Sinne des Paragraphen einhundertdreißig STGB, erfüllt,
nicht,
äh erfüllt äh auch vor dem Hintergrund der Pressefreiheit noch nicht den Tatbestand der Volksverhetzung, das heißt auch diese äh Fake News, dass das geschehen wäre, ähm erfüllt nicht den äh Staat hat, Bestand der Volksverhetzung und war also damit
immer noch äh nicht ähm illegal. Und würde äh auch in Zukunft ähm.
Nicht verboten. Nicht illegal werden durch dieses neue Gesetz.
Und ähm gleichzeitig wissen wir ja, dass sie, dass sie also sagen, äh.
Also wenn selbst so etwas legal ist und das eine wir das aber als das perfekte Beispiel von strafbaren Falschnachrichten haben.
Dann fragt man sich natürlich ähm wie.
Facebook und Twitter in Zukunft wissen sollen, was denn eine offensichtlich
Rechtswidriger Inhalt sein soll, den sie zu entfernen haben. Es gibt ja keine einheitige Rechtssprechung dazu und es gibt einen klaren Fall, dass selbst dieser Fall da Gina äh Gina Lisa sorry. Dieser Lisa-Fall ähm,
offenbar nicht rechtswidrig war. So, jetzt darf man offenbar und ähm.
Ja und vor allem wenn's keine keine wirklich konkreten und auch leicht zu verstehenden Anhaltspunkte gibt. Wie soll etwas offensichtlich sein.
Hatten wir, glaube ich, ja auch schon mal unter dem Aspek
diskutiert offensichtlich für wen, ja? Also für einen ausgebildeten Staatsanwalt und erfahrenen Polizeiermittler oder äh ein Restaurantbetreiber oder was auch immer.
Ne? Und jetzt fragst du dich, woher soll Facebook und Twitter das denn wissen? Entsprechend hat der äh war hier auch die Anfrage von äh äh von Golem ähm
Es gibt uns doch mal ein Beispiel, ja? Und dann antwortet der äh Sprecher Philipp Scholz, also der Sprecher von Heiko Maas,
Da das Ministerium einzelne Äußerungen in sozialen Netzwerken juristisch nicht bewertet, werden wir ihnen auch kein Beispiel eine strafrechtlich relevanten Beitrags,
nennen können. Also selbst die können es nicht. Das ist wirklich.
Du fragst dich echt, was da in diesem Laden los ist.
Datenschutz, also ich meine.
Du fragst dich ernst, also diese, es ist beängstigend und das ist in diesem Artikel sehr schön nochmal herausgearbeitet, deswegen empfehle ich ihn hier. Ähm du merkst so richtig, dass die.
Dass das Getriebene sind,
die versuchen in irgendwelche, in irgendwelche Winde äh ihre Fahne zu halten, egal aus welchem Arsch diese Winde kommen. Und das ist wirklich ähm das ist wirklich ein ein Problem.
Wer das so.
Wenn so die äh die die Justiz in Deutschland äh gelenkt wird.
Ja und vor allem die Gesetzgebung auch äh weiterentwickelt wird. Also ich meine man wenn man noch nicht mal ein Beispiel nennen kann.
Also noch nicht mal ein, mein gewisser Hinsicht, sie hätten ja auch sagen können wir geben euch jetzt mal ein hypothetisches,
Beispiel, ja? Etwas, wo jetzt hier nicht äh einzelne Äußerungen irgendwelcher konkreter Personen oder so, sondern so man stelle sich da nur mal vor, dass folgendes passiere,
oder in wir sagen jetzt nicht ganz genau, aber das wurde mal äh gesagt, wir sagen euch jetzt nicht im Kontakt. Das kann doch wohl nicht wahr sein. Und ich finde auch,
da weiß ich aber jetzt nicht, fällt mir jetzt weder der Begriff ein, noch die Praxis, aber es gibt doch auch.
So ein Gebot, das ein neues Gesetz auch sehr konkret zu sein hat. Also ein ein Gesetz muss, es muss erkennbar sein aus dem Gesetz, was gemeint ist.
Da gibt's irgend so einen Fachbegriff, der mir natürlich jetzt entfallen ist.
Und ich meine so wenn man sich noch nicht mal ein hyperthetisches Beispiel irgendwie einfallen lassen kann wo wo ja also dann dann kann ja diese Maßgabe nicht äh erfüllt sein.
Maßgabe, Orte.
Hoffentlich ist der bald weg, damit diese dummen Maß zweierlei Maß Wortwitze irgendwie äh wegfallen.
Aber weißt du, also genau dafür gönnst du dir diesen ganzen Rechtsstaat Overhead, dass du irgendwie eine vernünftige Justiz hast, die mit einem klugen,
kühlen Kopf die Regeln des Zusammenlebens macht und die dann und hier reden wir von irgendwelchen enorm hohen Geldstrafen,
Die irgendwie der Wirtschaft ein Heim fallen sollen und die haben sich, die haben noch nicht mal irgendwie in irgendeiner Form diesen Mist zu Ende gedacht. Und genauso möchtest du nicht
dass Gesetze geschrieben werden, du möchtest, dass äh Leute sehr überlegt mit diesen Dingen umgehen und diese diese aus dieser Maßecke
kommen halt immer nur irgendwie solche das müssen wir verbieten. Äh Dinger, die dann und im Zweifelsfall krasser Weise, ne, merkst du auch, das läuft ja gut für den
läuft bei ihm. So, finden alle mal gut. Ja, der Mast, der macht jetzt was gegen den Hass im Internet, geile Sache, so. Als nächstes macht er, also ich will nicht wissen, wogegen der als nächstes was macht, so.
Keine Ahnung, was der noch alles verbieten wird. Falsch parken oder so, könnte man mal verbieten, ist auch ein großes Problem.
Ja, wir können ja auch mal was machen. Wir tun was gegen Dummheit in Regierung.
Was denn? Ja. Können wir jetzt nicht so genau sagen, weil auf konkrete äh Politiker möchten wir an dieser Stelle nicht eingehen, aber so generell äh tun wir was, ne?
Ähm jetzt sagt er äh wird am Ende des Artikels noch zitiert ähm Thomas Herzombek, der ähm,
würde ich sagen, so der, der Netzpolitiker der CDU in den entsprechenden Ausschüssen vertreten und entsprechend aktiv. Mir fällt kein.
Stärker Netzpolitiker irgendwie aus der CDU ein. Ähm der ähm sagt also,
Setzt sich auch dafür ein, diese Bekampf, die ähm Bekämpfung von Falschnachrichten aus dem Gesetz ganz wegzulassen und sozusagen was weiß und was nicht, muss letztlich der Leser entscheiden. Wir brauchen einfach ein dringendes Recht auf
Gegendarstellung, sodass am Ende Meinung gegen Meinung steht. Und ich kann dem nur, kann dem nur beipflichten, dass man sagt, hier ähm wir wollen.
Meinungsfreiheit haben und für die und auch
ein Meinungsbildung haben. Wir wollen die Leute nicht zensieren, wir wollen Sachen nicht verbieten, aber es muss eben einfach wenn wir die Gefahr sehen, dass irgendwo sich solche Filterbibels bieten oder irgendwelche Lügen erzählt werden, dann muss dem eben mit der Wahrheit oder mit einer anderen Perspektive entgegengetreten werden.
Und viel weiter denke ich darf ein Staat auch gar nicht gehen.
Ja, zumal man ja, wie wir auch wissen und schon immer gesagt haben,
am Ende auch nichts dagegen tun können wird. Also äh da da kannst du noch so viele Gesetze erlassen. Diese Nachrichten werden kursieren und da braucht's ganz,
Andere äh Dynamiken in der Gesellschaft und im Netz, um das äh um dem Einhalt zu gebieten und dieses Gegendarstellungsding,
wie es ja im Prinzip auf Facebook jetzt probiert, hatten wir ja auch schon drüber gesprochen, so dieses
Ja, kannst du schon posten, aber dann ist es vielleicht scheiße, weil gucke mal hier, wir haben da äh Erkenntnisse bereits gewonnen aus, zumindest von uns vertrauten
Quellen, dass es vielleicht einfach mal Quatsch ist so und da werden jetzt gerade keine Kinderporno ähm Ringe in Pizzerias betrieben im Keller,
wo das Gebäude noch niemanden klar hat. So
ja und denkt doch mal drüber nach. Und du hast ja auch selber deine Erfahrung mit unbedingt doch nochmal drüber nach System irgendwie das das kann im Internet durchaus helfen.
Die Trolldrossel.
Die Trolldrossel so, ne? Und und das das ist halt auch so, so dieses ja, kannst du machen, aber dann ist halt Scheiße, denk mal drüber nach
nimmt, einfach glaube ich vielen Leuten den Wind aus dem See und in gewisser Hinsicht würde man, glaube ich, auch den Menschen damit helfen, weil ich glaube, das ist auch so ein Lernprozess,
Selbst ich ertappe mich immer wieder mal dabei so äh habe eine niedrige Quote glaube ich, es liegt vielleicht so äh einmal alle zwei Monate, ja, dass ich dann auch mal irgendwas getwitter und mir danach denke, so Alter, sag mal,
Geht's noch? Und dann während ich noch während ich noch so mir denke, so ob's das jetzt so war, hagelt es dann halt auch schon, wie die ersten.
Das Ding war mal nicht gut abgesegnet und falsch formuliert und tradala, guck mal klar. Also ja okay.
Kommen wir da also wir bräuchten echt so eine Trolldrossel für Maß.
Lasse Zeit.
Komm. Ja. Lass es sein. Hör lieber ein bisschen schöne Musik.
Ja jetzt äh muss ich meine Veranstaltung ankündigen. In dem Fall sogar eigentlich so ein bisschen einer an der ich selber ähm.
Genau, das ist nämlich unser Terminblock. Wer das noch nicht weiß, äh diese Musik kündigt euch immer an. Das ist mal wieder was zu besuchen gibt, was äh in unserer Empfehlungsliste gelandet ist und diesmal ist es so ein bisschen in eigener Sache, oder?
Genau, vom fünften bis siebten Mai in Berlin findet nämlich der G dreiundzwanzig Gipfel statt. Ähm.
Muss ich jetzt das Wortspiel erklären? Also der G zwanzig die Vorbereitung für den G zwanzig Gipfel in Hamburg sind natürlich auf Hochtouren äh in Berlin findet dann dieses Jahr der G
Dreiundzwanzig Gipfel statt und der hat es sich zum Ziel gesetzt, äh viele Menschen und Gruppen, die ein verschiedenen Projek
im Spannungsfeld von Kunsttechnik und Politik arbeiten, einfach mal zusammenzubringen. Wir wollen ein Wochenende lang äh die Zeit nehmen,
Kontakte auszubauen, alte Kontakte zu pflegen äh und ein bisschen zu schauen, was denn andere so machen und wie man sich denn so vernetzen kann. Also eine
gestaltete Welt vernetzen ist das Motto des G dreiundzwanzig Gipfels in diesem Jahr und äh wir sind natürlich empört, dass der G zwanzig Gipfel in Hamburg einen billigen Abklatsch unseres Mottos äh wird genutzt, nämlich eine
vernetzte Welt gestalten. Das ist also so ein Unsinn, ne? Das ist ja totaler Quatsch. Ähm.
Also der G dreiundzwanzig Gipfel richtet sich also an Leute, die irgendwelchen Projekten aktiv sind, äh die Interesse an Vernetzung, Kooperation und solchen.
Einem einen Ausbau der der Aktivitäten und ein Blick über den Tellerrand hinaus äh haben und findet statt vo
fünften bis siebten Mai in Berlin. Am fünften fangen wir abends an mit irgendwie so einem, sage ich mal
losen, laungigeren äh Konzept, dass man so mal aufeinander trifft und ein bisschen auch den nächsten Tag plant. Das Ganze ist also sehr offen gehalten, so Barcamp mäßig. Ähm.
Am Samstag ist dann tagsüber der Gipfel und ähm am Samstagabend ist dann auch eine kleine Party. Diese Party.
Gipfelparty.
Gipfelparty. Die Gipfelparty ist natürlich dann auch äh anderen Leuten offen, die also sagen, Mensch, ich habe Lust mit dieser mit dieser Crew zu feiern, aber ich habe jetzt vielleicht beim Gipfel selber äh nicht unbedingt was beizutragen oder oder auch keinen Bock, mir das alles zu geben,
ist also die Party.
Ein Schrei nach Groupies.
Äh die Party wird auf jeden Fall auch äh denke ich mal ganz nett, die geht dann so wahrscheinlich um zweiundzwanzig Uhr oder so los.
Das Ganze ist in Berlin sehr zentral gelegen und auf der Webseite steht noch nicht wo das ist, aber ich denke die paar Tage vorher kann man das echt schon sagen. Ähm.
David, ich weiß, kriege ich jetzt einen auf den Sack, wenn ich sage, wo.
Da hilft es nicht irgendwie, also.
Es hilft ja die die Veranstaltung findet statt im Seelchen am Holzmarkt.
Das ist zentral in Kreuzberg Friedrichshain, je nachdem Friedrichshain, also in.
Friedrichshain ist, auf der auf der Spree Seite ist, dass Friedrichshain oder Mitte und.
Äh der Bezirk heißt ja Kreuzberg Friedrichshain, aber es ist sehr bezüglich. Ach so, Entschuldigung. Ach.
Friedrichsthain-Kreuzberg heißt der Bezirk, ich bitte dich. Und Kreuzberg ist einfach nur Westfriedrichshain.
Ich hole hier gleich meine meine Wasserkanone raus.
Ähm,
Genau, findet da statt. Ähm Samstag also äh tagsüber und Nacht und Sonntag gibt's dann noch so ein bisschen Frühstück und Ausklang und wir freuen uns über interessierte politische Gruppierungen, die da teilnehmen und wir freuen uns natürlich auch über interessierte
Soloaktivisten, Aktivistinnen und Leute, die Bock haben auf 'ne schöne Party in Berlin.
Dafür haben wir aber einen äh Vorverkauf. Man braucht muss also ein Ticket äh kaufen, wenn man ähm.
Dorthin möchte. Tickets gibt's äh bei uns in den Shownotes oder unter Tickets Punkt G dreiundzwanzig Punkt EU Slash G dreiundzwanzig Slash G dreiundzwanzig. Ähm allgemeine Informationen einfach unter G dreiundzwanzig Punkt,
EU und wir freuen uns natürlich, wenn ihr dann dort seid.
Ja und jetzt äh sind wir am Ende dieser Sendung angekommen.
Ich denke schon.
Für euch.
Weißt du, für uns nicht.
Ach ging so. Fand's eigentlich ganz beschwingend.
Apropos beschwingt. Wir könnten ja nochmal ähm den Cybermarsch zum Ausklang spielen.
Nochmal. Ah.
Es gibt ja vielleicht eine beschwingtere Version davon.
Mal gucken.
Mehr habe ich eigentlich glaube ich nicht mehr zu sagen. Ah, ich muss noch danken, ich muss danken.
Außer dieser ganz ganz wichtigen Information, die du seit Jahren verdrängst.
Welche denn?
Weiß ich nicht. Das muss man gleich sagen.
Ich muss noch jemandem danken und ich hab's aber jetzt leider ähm den ich hab's jetzt gerade versemmelt und mache das beim nächsten Mal. Tut mir sehr leid.
Der Zettel liegt zu Hause.
So ist das manchmal.
So ist das im Leben eines auf Almosen angewiesenen.
Angewiesen werden. Powerneds, da wird's dann irgendwie äh verzittelt man sich manchmal. Wie man so schön sagt. Wir sagen tschüss, bis bald.
Bis dahin, ciao ciao.